[Music]
foreign
we're back full disclosure we are
recording this podcast
after we just got off the flight which
is why whitney is dressed like a madam
you
like a gypsy traveler raise your arms up
people listen to a podcast
look at that know what i look like they
will eventually tune into youtube
jealous of what i'm wearing
i really am it's like a wizard coach why
i came in here and you
just were full of rage because we're not
on our house some of us had to wear
our suitcase clothes lucky for me it's
our merch
he came right from the airport and
benton is irate
that he didn't get to contour before we
shot this podcast
you could have borrowed stuff beard yeah
that is my contour
i walked in here i decided i'd dress up
for you guys because i didn't want to
look like a
slob and i put on a cute little sweater
that i've been i actually ordered this
sweater to wear on a date
good that's what i was just going to say
it's a good day it's a great date
sweater
makes you look rich which is rare
[Applause]
but i realized that when i start dating
someone i instantly start buying
clothes for dates with them clothes i
think they will like
and it's sick it's sick
i start buying the clothes for the
person that i think
the guy wants you're a shape-shifter
yeah
i start just sort of becoming a costume
designer for this zach braff movie
of like the natalie portman character
and i was like oh i'm gonna buy like
fun cozy like i don't wear shit like
this sorry for you guys that are just
listening
it's like a belly shirt it's like a crop
it's a question i'm not this person who
is this person
it's a cropped crocheted sweater with a
high neck and
mutton sleeves is it mutton lamb
yeah but mutants that's what they're
called like what about who is this
person
why am i doing this i mean it's about
time so then i was like you know what
fuck it i'm not going to save this for a
date i'm going to wear it
but don't worry i didn't buy it for a
guy that i met on
a dating app but don't you worry for me
because if you're listening she's still
wearing shark teeth earrings
i am i love these you don't like these
does she want you know that she's
vicious
uh i do like those so anyway benton is
usual
as per usual as jealous of my top
angelita your boogie
um so just i'm always insecure about
these opens i never think they're good
enough
or funny enough or sharp enough or
informative enough but today i'm
especially insecure
because i we just flew back from denver
colorado i
always forget about the altitude in
denver dude
that city roofies you
the second you get in you're just
out dude dizzy i have no idea what just
happened
i came back i had to take a nap which is
so different than every other day
i can't believe you had to think i do
have the schedule of the toddler
benjamin knows this and she's shocked i
was like a nap you no
i have to nap twice a day so that lucky
you're awake now so that i don't turn
into cruella de vil
but your epiphany mm-hmm that you're
gonna have
your um your iud taken out
well you just said that with a lot of
pomp you're tiny your tiny crossbow
you're having it removed
i am the guard of the gate
letting him off duty
i the keeper of the cave
letting him go what a horrible visual
i'm done now
it's not a cave it's a tiny garage
is cardi b called a tiny garage for for
what little clown cars
like children's jeeps like what are you
talking about
children's jeeps um okay
so here's the deal i have been on birth
control since i was like
15. okay not
what stop doing math in your head just
trying to see what year that would be
wow
wow he's like fine um
i did it uh i did it more because i had
headaches i had migraines at a very
young age and a doctor put me on birth
control i've been on birth control ever
since
it's not ideal to be on birth control
this long
but i've had to uh because of my
headaches
on friday what your headaches my sexy
teenage headaches so anyway i was just
like a hot teenager that did a lot of
fucking and had really bad headaches
from your head hitting the headboard
no so i'm going off my iud
this week switching to something else
but in order to switch to the new
uh iud it's like a little calamari that
i have to jam up into my
yeah uterus which i've heard is tilted
a doctor specifically i i was taught in
i mean it's a tricky diagnosis it's like
a fair ride it's just
round and around it's still it's jilted
for sure
i don't know about tilted but i've had
two different doctors one told me that i
had a small uterus
and one told me that i had a tilted
uterus i i don't know if it's tilted i
think i'm just arching my back
because a stranger's hand is inside my
body
i actually think i think that might be
why it's tilted
sir this is before i knew there were
female gynecologists
like i didn't even i was just like why
am i going to some guy named bob for my
gynecology
i love that why don't i go to a lady
named mary
yeah mary and bob's gynecology center
yeah why like
why are guys even gynecologists i'm
sorry it's just like a it's a weird
call because only men could be doctors
for a real long time
it feels like are we are we good on that
like shouldn't we just have women do
gynecology for a while don't do what
you're passionate about
that's what they say okay i'm just
saying
i just if you're going into gynecology
now as a man is like kind of a wild
decision but listen you've been on your
birth control for a long time now
i've been on birth control for a very
long time so that means your hormones
are used to what they're used to well
i'm just scared i'm going this
wednesday i'm having my iud taken out
and i it's my personality is such a
delicate balance of neural chemicals and
hormones
your walking pharmacy
[Applause]
and sodas and caffeine
that i'm just i have no idea who i am
off birth control
i i don't know myself as an adult
hormone off birth control well maybe
it'll change
no i'm sorry i mean there's medically no
way can't wait to meet me i mean
what's the worst that could happen
you're gonna grow a forked tongue
i don't know are guys into that i mean
you're gonna be like you're gonna
overthink more things like what i mean
what could possibly happen you'll take
more naps
you know maybe maybe the opposite like
really amazing things will happen to you
like your hair will grow longer and your
eyes will get brighter and your nipples
will get pinker like maybe that'll be
what happens
my nipples are pretty pink i said pinker
[Laughter]
maybe that'll happen maybe you're being
too negative about it merch alert
pinkneck bigger batter pinker
and um i talked about it on my hbo
special but when women are
on birth control essentially we start to
smell pheromones in men differently
because our body
thinks it's pregnant i mean you're
essentially pregnant that's why you
can't get pregnant that's what birth
control does it makes your body think
that you're pregnant so it doesn't shed
your uterine
lining
i like that i do it's so amazing what
women's bodies can do
um it's just one big magic trick
nightmare
and so you're attracted to a different
kind of man when you're on birth control
and when you're off birth control
as apparently when you're on i explained
this very elegantly
pain is my friend i broke my shoulder
didn't go to the doctor
for four days i can handle pain i have a
high tolerance for pain or you're just
that's just dumb
yeah not going to the doctor because you
broke your shoulder what well i just
i have a high tolerance for pain is my
point when i got the iud put in
i not only did i fly
off the bed and i hit my head on the
back wall i puked afterwards it hurt so
bad
no you thought it was like there was a
weird pain in the center of your body
because it was like where a soul should
be
it would be it's an empty place
you're like what is that it was an
exorcism
you didn't even know they're gonna go
you don't have an iud you're like damn
i just swore i did those are the little
sticks from the blair witch project
almost choked
that little bundle that is what it kind
of looks like though
the iud is just like it's a sketchy
device
those little bundles of sticks are
called fetishes too yeah i have a fetish
up in my uterus
for sure and i'm gonna get it taken out
which is a whole other fetish
i bet i could video and put it on only
fans and make some cash
oh that's a that's a niche market should
we put my iud on ebay
for charity wait will they give it back
to you or is it or is it that's gonna be
a medical way
i don't know if you can keep your iud or
not that's a really good my dad kept his
hip bone
his polio infested hip bone looks wild
where is it i have a picture of it
somewhere but he got his hip removed
yeah he had hit his head replaced
because he had polio so he had it
replaced and then now the hip bone just
sits on a shelf in our hunting
room you know i want to know more about
it
well you know that's interesting you
would have thought
after two years you would have known i
had a hunting room
you you know you should elaborate on
that
point it's just a room full of guns and
bullets my dad reloads shells in there
and stuff
and it has like guns and all kinds of
things
what else ben 10 is in the hunting room
how many nut things you're gonna like
the only interesting thing
i've heard today what else
there's lots of bullets i think there's
some grenades uh
um there's ak-47s i think are in there
from where i don't know where my dad got
him
they're all legal though he has licenses
for everything what does he do with them
and their grenades don't work they're
like shells of grenades just so
everyone's clear
okay um uh he there's i mean he shoots
things with them what do you mean what
do you say with the guys
he shoots deer squirrels
whatever you can shoot with a gun
legally shooting at squirrels probably
takes a lot of skill they're so sweet i
mean they stopped
they stop and stand they they don't move
forever they're
not sharks they don't swim in circles um
what do you mean they stop and stand
they stop like they're not running
around when you shoot them you wait for
them to stop and then you shoot it
yeah but the second you shoot it doesn't
adhere it and then get all wily well
when you shoot it it's dead so it won't
do anything
i need to know more about your iud
because you said i heard somebody that
lady told you i had to have an epidural
oh she literally said to me
the doctor was like uh after my reaction
to getting the iud
put in my uterus maybe i've just not
maybe i've just
i don't know maybe guys haven't gone
deep enough i don't i don't know what's
happening that my uterus was so
unscathed in that area i had a virgin
uterus uh she was like you're gonna have
to have an epidural when you have a kid
i was like first of all i will be buying
a kid let's be honest
well can't wait for that text message at
three in the morning
i need a kid where can we find one and
the 14 follow-up messages did we get it
is it on the way where's the kid is the
kid coming do we get a kid
let's rush it can you rush it can you
call about the kid that's not the kid i
ordered
yeah that's not this i ordered two sizes
because i didn't know what size i wanted
so can we rewind do you think that
do you think that dicks reach your
uterus i don't know i as soon as i said
it i got
uh distracted and confused i don't know
that much about
that's what willy wonka asked dick if
it's going all the way up there this is
the elephant in the living room women
know nothing about our own vaginas
uh i couldn't tell you they're between
labia and a clitoris
i i truly don't know i thought i was
laying eggs like i don't under i don't
know
no one teaches us my generation wasn't
taught about our own vaginas
well truly got a pocket mirror time to
learn no thank you
no i'm good i feel like that ship has
sailed i feel like i would have rather
have learned about it
in its glory days um when i was a kid
but you're gonna uh you're gonna get a
kid have a kid buy a kid have a kid okay
so here's what i've decided because
when you're touring comedian you have to
plan out your whole
year you know because basically i'm
touring next
fall i think all the rescheduled dates
from kovit are now going to be fall
2021 i'm just turning 38 years old
tick-tock i'm not talking about the app
or am i
i need to think about what i'm gonna
have a kid and i was like you know what
i for the longest i guess so many like
hollywood people have had kids on their
own that it stopped being cool
to have a kid on your own yeah now you
guys just happens you can eat them
time to stay young we know what you're
doing for the adrenacrom
yeah is that real no i mean surely not
okay
let's not get into that but let's say
sorry i will say that um
i don't want pizza emojis all over my
instagram it would be nice for you are
you gonna are you you're just gonna have
the babies just you
here's what i'm thinking i don't like i
guess i just i don't
want anyone to be sad for me like i'm
just a snob
about the people i date and i love my
life
and i love my animals and i love my
friends and if i
find someone great but i also like i'm
down to have a kid on my own
but the only reason i don't want to is
because i don't want people to be like
she's so brave and triumphant and
i'm just like that's not true i'm not
i'm i'm the opposite of brave i'm scared
of involving a person that annoys me and
leaves their hoodies everywhere
and their wet towels on my bed so i'm
just gonna do it alone it's not an act
of
resistance it's an act of uh
cowardice okay well
if the baby doesn't have a dad who will
remember the baby's name and birthday
you you're the no i'm the dad and you're
the mom and i just want to know i'm the
dead beat dad
and you're the baby's mom you have to be
really clear that you know that
babies are people and one day they will
grow up
and not like you for about seven years
they'll have different you know thoughts
feelings opinions are you ready for that
oh so they'll be like my instagram
followers
they'll be like they'll live here
they're like a live comment section
yeah they'll be like your channel
they're going to live in your house and
if you hit them you go to jail
you can't block him or anything so just
i have a gaggle of bitches that would
help me raise
who are also all comedians yeah female
comedians raising a baby it'll be like
um labyrinth david bowie and labyrinth
all the gremlins goblins goblin
do i mean it'll be like the um the craft
your favorite
okay it'll be like a bunch of childless
witches raising a babe
you didn't watch that movie because it
didn't turn out good
it'll be like rosemary's baby yeah it'll
be great it'll end fine
but you're gonna do it but you might do
it by yourself i think i might in a year
because here's the thing i don't want i
i am
all for having babies late if you're a
woman that's great
godspeed janet jackson had a baby at 50.
good for you
right i think chloe seven yay had one at
45 i just don't want to do that i can do
that i believe women should be able to
do that
i don't want to be an older mom i truly
i want to be able to
beat up my kid and win i want to be
fat i want to be able to beat my kid in
a race it's safe to say you will not
be getting to adopt a kid if someone
listens back to this
yeah the adoption marker will be like no
not ideal this is not ideal
if i decide to adopt we're going to have
to take this down
uh it won't be the first time we had to
take a podcast down really quickly
um but i want i i do want to make sure
i'm like
physically available to fight
my kid back if it attacks me no what are
you planning on raising this kid in a
trailer park why are you fighting
well here's the thing i am you should be
creating precious i might be
i might be projecting because i was a
punk ass kid
i when my parents got divorced i got so
angry
when my mom started dating a new guy
i'm not proud of this i can't believe
i'm admitting it but
my mom started dating a new guy and i
got mad at her one day and i called her
a hooker
i thought this would be so much better
than that that's all you said she
smacked me
across the face and i've hit the floor
hit the floor and literally the second i
hit the floor i was like you're
right you're right and every time i talk
to my mom i'm like thank you for doing
that
forever the dramatics hitting the floor
i was like you
full telenovela spin yeah dude
she hit me so hard and she was so
fucking right to do so what was the
guy's name um
i just want to know who got you slept
ron i think right
wrong like not even worth it ron mom but
sometimes i mean and i also i'm not like
i don't know i just i don't want to be
50 and like cutting up orange slices for
soccer practice like i'm not i'm going
to be
when i'm 50 i'm going to be in bed like
the grandpa from charlie and the
chocolate factory
no matter what age you are you're not
cooking for the kid i hope that would
you let somebody else take care of that
i'm just saying i don't want to have a
kid late i know that's
is that not a feminist thing to say i
can i just don't want to
you can do whatever you want that's
feminist that's exactly
right i feel like i'm not being forced
to have a kid yeah who are you arguing
with i don't know
about me and my is anyone watching many
personalities no it's like i just feel
like now there's this pressure
for me to have a kid later so that i can
like be a role model or something like
if i have a kid i like sell out
oh yeah they're like what'd you save
that money up for i know you're just
like oh you're just gonna have a kid
you're just gonna like
it's like well yeah yeah buy a water
slide yeah i mean
i don't know but i i do think i would do
the donor thing sperm donor i
started uh uh dipping my toe into the
donor pool of sperm that's gross
it's a gross thing to say i was on an
airplane in a pandemic that's the least
gross thing i've
seen today in my brain um
here's the thing the sperm donor market
is a sketchy market
it's a wild like it's like an app
basically or a website it's like a
dating app or a website and all the
photos of the guys come up
and they're all like 22 and hot they all
look like hitler's
dream like they all look like nazis
they're like gorgeous blondes with like
blue eyes it's kind of uncomfortable
you were just on okay cupid weren't you
yes you were like i don't understand why
they're asking me so many questions
and when you're looking for someone
that's solely a donor and not
a boyfriend or potential husband it's
such a different experience it's so
liberating because you're just like
height height weight height like that
all you give a fuck about
and i it's like is that what it's like
to be a straight guy going on apps i was
like this is so much easier
like i don't have to like check if
you're oh you're only working look
that's all i gave a shit about even on
the sperm donor sites they have these
little bios
that say like their interests and like
once like i went to harvard law school
i'm like i don't give a fuck
where you went i don't care what first
off you went to harvard law school
and you're giving jerking off into a cup
for money something went very wrong
well maybe that's how you paid for
harvard law school i was thinking about
this
when you brought this up maybe that's
how you paid for it and that might make
that baby a little survivor which would
be a great skill to have
in a home where we just leave pans
burning and tubs running and candles lit
doors wide open i mean
i don't care about my sperm donors
interests
it was like loves to swim i don't give a
fuck how tall are you
i want my donor offspring to be able to
pull himself out of a ravine if
necessary
i don't care what he does on the
weekends oh the best is one that's like
the sperm donor sites are like
uh good sense of humor i'm like that has
nothing that's not your genetics that's
not you don't inherit a good sense of
humor
you get a good sense of humor from a bad
childhood that's not well your kid will
be a hoot
[Laughter]
and what are you gonna do you're gonna
build them feed them banana bread
pancakes
some vegan whipped cream it's weird also
because the the donors
that they're more expensive some are
more expensive than others
and the ones that are the most expensive
are the ones that have yielded the most
the biggest brood if you will what the
ones that get the most women pregnant
are the ones that are the most expensive
the most
white sperm i know it's like racehorses
that is
course sex trafficking so i'm wait i'm
so stuck on the fact that like the more
kids they have the more money they i
know it's intense so now your
kid's just gonna have a bunch of
siblings that they don't know about
that feels like abuse but i have a lot
more questions about your iud
oh i prepared for a very long time um
i kept yelling at benton yesterday on a
sunday to prepare for this open because
i just could not get my shit together
so he's written five pages and also on
the airport and also on the plane
yes uh and in the uber
yeah i cracked the whip um
23andme you never finished your sentence
what's the big thing the thing about the
23rd me is
it's more that if i have two kids let's
say i have two donor kids this is an
ethical dilemma
do you want to have them both from the
same donor or do you do
different donors like do you want them
to have
well you want to make it then i'm in a
relationship with a donor
yeah but you want them to have an escape
plan so it might be easier for them to
have the same donor
are you jealous that i'm not are you
worried about them having a lot
no are you worried about them having a
lot of
um siblings they don't know i have a lot
of siblings i don't know
and it's worked out fine okay what i
just wonder because you told me in the
hotel you thought i was incesty and that
has really stuck in my head
well it is i don't know what kind of
greek tragedy your children are gonna be
living through what god's cursed them to
fucking their siblings here's the thing
i learned that i had a bunch of siblings
half siblings that i didn't know and
when i
learned that i was like i'm gonna fuck
them what if i've dated one of them like
well i don't know
but then uh uh we talked about how
you smell the pheromones of siblings and
they're repellent to you so if someone
smells bad to you if a guy smells really
bad to you
or a girl smells really bad to you
there's a chance that you're related in
some way
or he's wearing axe body spray
amanda sterny's on the pod we get really
granular about how she got famous
on instagram about what influencing is
how to do it
she did it all herself she didn't wait
around for someone else to do it for her
she didn't wait around for the
gatekeepers
she just fucking buckled down she taught
herself how to edit look at her and go
okay i can do this like i think for me
i was so like who do i need to be on
social media
and it's just like you just need to be
yourself and the best version of
yourself and if you have like
you know negative traits that are
holding you back like go
fix them you know like find a way to
um make sure that your heart shines
through in what you do publicly
social media and make sure that when
someone looks at your stuff
because your social is everything now
it's your storefront that
people have put you in like a positive
folder
in their brain yeah when they think of
you they think of something positive i
mean i
we in the podcast you talk a lot about
her like her career and job and how she
does all that
but for me it's really i'm really
interested in who someone is when the
camera's off and like the listeners
should know that she is like
such i think that comes through i mean i
think it is too but i mean like
there are people that i think on camera
you know you don't know you don't know
what someone is when they're
on camera who they're not i don't think
you can fake something for two and a
half hours i think that's the thing
about podcasts and i think that's why
podcasts are changing uh entertainment
so much because i don't think you can
fake it for two and a half hours and
there's there are people that will not
come on this podcast and publicist won't
let them come on this podcast because
they know
i can go on jimmy kimmel for eight
minutes and pretend to be a good person
but you can't get away with it for two
years yeah and she is i mean
that little interaction meeting i'm
really thankful that you
brought amanda to us and we got to meet
her because i mean that little
interaction that we had in your backyard
i mean that like
refilled my cup i felt like yeah she's
cool divacup
i'm applied i also um also there's a
live a lot of epiphanies with her like
her coming into my life made me realize
a lot of old programming that i had that
i needed to look at and work on so
i'm excited for you guys to hear it um
sorry bent and i are so tired i'm gonna
go back to bed
uh whitneycomings.com more tour dates
are being added
have been added merch uh
comes out october 9th all that new merch
that you guys love that benton is
wearing
right now is on sale love you
enjoy amanda sir hernia
bye we now take a break in our regularly
scheduled programming
to talk about one of my favorite things
two of my favorite things frankly
balls love them can't get enough of them
the only the only problem with dicks and
balls
and as you may have guessed we're
talking about manscaped right now
and i'm so glad this company exists
because
balls were not set up to win they were
placed
in a very unfortunate area of the body a
place that does not get much sunlight
does not get much ventilation that is
downright swampy and that's not
your fault and up until now there were
not a lot of products that were
especially designed
to clean those stalactites
but now we have manscaping now we have
they just released their products in the
uk
canada and australia ooh now i can start
dating guys in the uk canada and
australia
they also just released their crop care
kit which is formulated bundle to give
you
a plus balls and the ultimate male
hygiene hat a
plus balls valedictorian balls the crop
care kit includes the crop preserver
which is the ball deodorant
uh the name speaks for i love the ball
deodorant the fact that this wasn't
around when i was in college
really oh it's very unfortunate it gets
better for you they also have a crop
reviver which is a ball
toner a spray-on toner that gives your
balls a little slice of heaven with
their aloe vera
and hazelnut extract not hazelnut
hazel but you're thinking about nuts
well i mean hazel has to cover hazelnut
right
but can i tell you balls again it's not
your fault balls look like dried
apricots i don't know why
the consistency of that skin is so thin
you have got to tone it
little aloe vera will really make a big
difference
i don't know what this the why that skin
always looks like
it's for temperature regulation oh
that's why the skin on balls is so
thin they're filled with sperm you guys
have oh that's true
you also get the crop cleanser which is
a body wash a full body sperm in there
take care of them
oh my gosh the future of humanity is in
these little sacks
preserve them revive them cleanse them
and mop them and mop them with ball
wipes you
never know mop ball wipes i love that
you never know when the opportunity will
strike so you should always be prepared
please be prepared
don't go into my bathroom and start
using my
expensive soap your eye creams well yeah
washing your balls with my expensive eye
creams and towels you can always tell
when a guy has tried to wash his scrotum
like really quickly in your bathroom
there's like water on the ceiling it's
like all around the scene yeah i know
it's like dude dude
so i'm like why do you feel like
patchouli
why do you smell like elizabeth arden
diamonds
white diamonds the kit also comes with
the foot duster which is a foot
deodorant love it that's a free gift
this is so great
and you get the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer
offers a replacement
ceramic blade with advanced skin safe
technology which helps reduce grooming
accidents it's replaceable ceramic blade
we're very tired guys we are
very hungover and jet lagged it's also
waterproof the formulas are all vegan
cruelty free die free sulfate free
paraben
free so good because here's the thing
about the lawnmower 3.0 this is i have
given these to men because i run a tight
ship
and what they tell me is that it doesn't
am i allowed to say this it doesn't cut
their balls yeah skin safe technology
yeah because it's like if you just use
like some
regular like janky rusty ass razor that
you got in a hotel for you it's gonna
rip your ball skin
there's a little light on it it's
waterproof it has a rechargeable stand
a light that's good and you get 20 off
and free shipping at manscape.com with
code
whitney you can use it on your butt
sorry some of you guys have very hairy
butts and it's
jarring it's jarring
i'm just saying some guys like fingers
in their butts now and if you want a
finger in your butt you got to make it a
hospitable
place yeah you're not pushing that
finger through a wicker basket
if you care for those beautiful balls of
yours all you have to do is go to their
site hit a few buttons on your phone and
it will change your life for the better
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com with code whitney
add some swag to your saggy bag this is
it guys this is
it shalom fresh
hello fresh um hey fresh
oh hey fresh what like i love the name
hell we'll get to the product in a
second but i love the name hello fresh
it's just such a positive like the two
best words in the english language and
one
thing hello fresh what how else is it
bonjour fresh bonjour false
satan french aloha french aloha friend
aloha frosh
hey fresh
you guys know hello fresh now is the
time to actually
act on your desire to order
hellofresh you've heard about it on
podcasts you've thought that's a good
idea
they just deliver amazing meal kits
to your home america's number one meal
kit number one meal kit i should do that
it saves you time money they're
delicious nutritious
i just heard about that on a podcast i
should do that i mean i should do that
person and i'll do that for like a year
i've been doing this see i i'm not it
takes me a while i'm like i should do
that i should totally that's such a
great idea
today's the day to act on that
idea hello fresh offers convenient
delivery to your doorstep
for easy home cooking with the family no
rigmarole you know me in rigamarole
i can't you go to the grocery store you
go or get all the stuff
you can't find it it's all in the weird
all the aisles are
wrong they put the ragu next to eggs now
you're like what this makes no sense you
forget half the ingredients and you get
home and you're like oh
i didn't get turmeric but with
hellofresh it all comes pre-measured in
a box
and then each meal comes in a little bag
you get a recipe kit
you can add things like garlic bread
tiny desserts you have to do dishes
after
sorry that's my main do you have to do
dishes after because you won't have to
cook with them
that's not true but i mean you could try
you don't have to do like all like it's
like cuts down like when i did the
uh my last it was the chickpea couscous
i just put it right in and then it was
like it was like two bowls opposed if i
had made chickpea couscous would be like
nine balls
oh yeah okay that's good math that is
yeah that's solid i'm gonna tell you
what he doesn't know how to cook so she
probably did use two bowls
um i can cook with hello but hellofresh
does give you
it tells you what you need it'll tell
you if you need bowls measuring it tells
you everything on the instructions very
easy
the meals are super it was still good
she just ate it cold
all right i can already tell you they're
also committed to giving
back hellofresh is committed to making
fresh delicious food available more than
now more than ever
they've taken extra steps to keep its
employees and customers safe during
uh with contactless delivery awesome um
all the packaging like the food they
leave in front of your door all the food
stays fresh
cold the meats are in there until you
get back and put it in your little
fridge
um it's great i also like that it's um
all the ingredients are already measured
for you
like you don't have to you know like the
measuring fucking spoons and the
things like you know yeah you never know
those are they'll just send you what you
need if you need both
what is this what is this one-fourth
half of a
cup squared the root of pie
like it's it's never the same it's like
wait is this in english sizes
it's like is this even do you know what
i mean yeah hello fresh take care of it
it's always like can you convert no
decibels is this fahrenheit like i don't
even know you can't even read the
ingredients and it doesn't match with
the little spoons you got
if you relate to this you really need
hellofresh
if any of that made any sense just just
order it go to hellofresh.com
good for you 80. what's your favorite
code well i'm currently on the calorie
smart program oh that's cool because i'm
trying to ruin your life
bye by losing all this weight stealing
all my clothes
getting so hot and being in a baywatch
movie
but yeah i did the calorie smart one and
i but if i'm not doing that i love like
they have a texas
mac and cheese one it's like all these
cheeses and it's like pepper
it's so good it's like spicy how long
does it take to cook i think that one
takes like literally
20 minutes for like i think it's a meal
for two or four you can get either one
oh and you can keep it like for the week
well yeah before the pandemic i made it
for friends one time we ate it was
really good oh
i didn't think about that one time i ate
it with nachos before i was on the
calorie smart plan
oh it was great that's a good call
i really am i get i'm like a creature of
habit i'll eat the same thing for like
two weeks and then i'll switch to
another like i don't
that's just my brain but the chickpea
couscous i'm super obsessed with
um it's not like too spicy and then
there's two chickens
there's a paprika chicken that makes me
feel very
worldly and then there's a
mediterranean chicken am i saying it
right i mean yes it's just like i just
i'm good with just
all the chickens are just like i feel
like i got my protein i got my
vegetables like i feel like i'm just
like
i can kind of uh be relaxed during the
day because i know
when i have a hell of fresh meal at
night i'm like get all the vitamins i
need so i can kind of eat trash during
the day
they probably don't want me to say this
in the ad but i just feel like i know
that i'm going to eat healthy
at night so i can kind of drink soda
again if you related to that please just
order the kit
and i'm this is no joke aside or this is
no joking
literally i've tried probably every meal
they make so far and i've never had a
bad one love it
never that's it ben benton doesn't lie
go to hellofresh.com good for you 80 and
use code good for you 80 to get a total
of 80
off including free shipping on your
first box that's hellofresh.com
good for you 80 and use code good for
you 80 to get 80
off including free shipping on your
first box
it's weird that we're friends yeah yeah
yeah
it's like let's be honest unexpected
yeah yeah say the least yeah
but it works so like i feel like we're
alike in a lot of ways
yeah like we look exactly like we have
the same exact box
the second me i have always wanted
or i'm the second you i guess or like
your third robot
fourth robot which would look exactly
like my rope
yeah just a huge compliment i mean that
was designed
by professionals the better version of
me without dead eyes
no but i i think the way that we met it
might not have been a big deal to you
but it was a big deal to me
it was yes it was a big deal to me too
we spend a lot of time in the show uh
over analyzing
and uh little tiny moments for like an
hour
no but when you and i met it was a big
deal because i as everyone on the show
knows
uh historically have some
i'm spooked a little bit by female
friendships i've had some heartbreak and
female friendships i grew up around
really
complicated sensitive women that i had
to walk on eggshells around
a lot of borderline personality disorder
and as a result i was in really toxic
friendships for a really long time
mm-hmm and when you and i met i was kind
of just getting back out there
oh really yeah wow because like the one
in the for my rebound yeah
jeez am i going to stay around because
rebounds usually don't i'm just
practicing
okay practicing um yeah but when i met
you it didn't come across like that at
all because like we were doing
david spade's show and that's how we
first met and then when we were
like going i'm like going to be with
comedians and i'm like i
do comedic acting i'm not a stand-up
comedian
and then i'm sitting there like about to
we're about to start with you guys and
i'm like okay well this is like
i'm a little bit nervous but then
immediately like you like you touch my
arm you're just like
oh it's like you're going to do great
you're going to and like so welcoming
made me feel a little patronizing yeah
yeah
gonna oh honey yeah good luck out there
no it's just for yourself
it was really genuine and it made me
more relaxed
and made me like i was so much more
comfortable i felt
good being there i felt good leaving
there i wanted to do the show again
even just because of you like so it just
made me you just made me feel really
good and
that's not and i'm not just saying that
like because
it's just not that normal which is weird
for
l.a or in life you know two things
happen
and i think that i never i couldn't have
done that 10 years ago
because i was programmed you're am i
allowed to ask your age
yeah 30 right you're 30 29 29 oh my god
i'm stuck bitch or three
um easy are you just hold on to that
last
i'm actually 35 i'm 45 i look great
just like always do it up i think that's
the best strategy
yeah just like i know people like
whitney lies better age i'm like no if i
was gonna do it i'd lie
up so that i seemed like i looked young
yes seventy-seven i looked
crazy wow you know but 10 i'm 38 so
if if if we had done that 10 years ago i
don't think it would have gone
up to me i don't think i would have been
mean to you like i think i would have
been
overly nice but saccharine and probably
not as genuine because i was insecure
and i was programmed to believe that
women were your competition
yeah like i grew up with a lot of that
shit yeah i mean that's how
a lot of everybody was raised i think
that's why like women
friendships are always like oh like so
hard to be friends with girls it's
because
we were kind of raised to always just be
in competition with each other to
compete to get the limited amount of
jobs that were like available to each
other
back or yeah the guys are like you know
so
yeah it's always been like that and now
it's like which is great
like i think the new generations
probably aren't gonna have that as much
i know it's like
you i can i tell you so amanda um
as you all know has whatever 25
million followers on instagram and
youtube and all that i'm probably
getting those numbers wrong
a little bit more like your age
i actually have this theory i had
there's this actress in hollywood
who always hated me and she was such a
fucking saboteur but it's the kind of
thing that like
no one could understand it she would
give you these like
backhanded compliments where she would
over compliment you to the point to
where you had to correct her and insult
yourself
you know what i mean that's like she's
cheering hey oh my god congratulations
oh my god i heard you just got that job
where um
uh you're doing that movie with denzel
washington congratulations no it's not
dude you have to be like no
actually it's a wayne's brother but okay
uh
like your achievement was minimized by
her over complimenting you
yeah like how did you i love that yeah i
know i'm like i'm like that's a really
that is my go-to move for the book
yeah uh she doesn't yeah well not about
that but she
did write a book i think at some point
but yeah she would be like oh my god i
heard you just bought a house oh my god
i'd be like yeah i did she's like oh my
god is that that one um oh my god that
one up in bel air
that was just for sale and i'm like nope
studio city uh it was not the belly i
was so proud of that until you just did
that yeah that was amazing
that's a good i've never heard of that
strategy it works such a mind fuck
yeah great how did you just hurt my
feelings on
my special day um yeah so
um but it's interesting because uh
when uh big name dropped liza koshy was
over
this weekend as well as you can tell by
my hat
your whole i was
i mean she does i'm trying to think i
don't think she was in a hat this
weekend
no i was just having a shitty hair day
and i put a hat on and now it looks like
i'm trying to be young
i don't think she was in a hat this
weekend like that would make it well she
wouldn't want to have an eyesore
like i feel like that's she could pull
that off yeah she's like the only person
that can like oh yeah oh yeah all the
time oh that's what you're saying yeah
but something interesting happened
where you were over and sh and i invited
her over too and i didn't tell
either of us why would i that'd be weird
and
i saw you both and i went oh my god i
hope they get along that was my first
really like my old reaction yeah the old
blueprint of women don't get along
especially
they're competitive with each other
because you're both really really famous
successful influencers
what is that am i sexist well what is
that
no because we're in the same industry
but different you know i don't know like
it's a normal thought to have because
it's like me bringing
if i brought a new female comedian now
that i know you i wouldn't
never do that yes are you fucking local
the female comedians i like are in my
house at all times
but i know if i brought one you would be
nice to her yeah of course
like you wouldn't and then you'd be like
don't do that again
so i'd be like okay i got it
well it just was interesting to me
because i was like oh my gosh i guess
this next generation of women likes each
other
this is wild yeah they support each
other you guys were like snuggling on
the sofa it was actually
you're wearing armor for a battle that's
over
the war is over that's what she told me
one time yeah
when did i tell you that when i was
talking about how i didn't like talking
to guys and i was rude to them and you
quit being rude to everybody that comes
in the house
because they were all guys all my lovers
do you intentionally be rude to them oh
on purpose
yeah because you were trying to hurt
them before they had a chance yeah
yeah i was like i want you to think i
don't i don't give a shit if you live or
die
yeah that's weird change did your
behavior change after that
yeah i think so i mean actually yeah
i think it happened before the pandemic
so now we haven't had people in the
house as much so i'm trying to think but
yeah i do remember remember that time we
went down to was it twitter or snapchat
or something
and people were like hi ben and you're
like hey like like exasperated that they
were saying hi to you
yeah sometimes it's a lot of work for me
but that's interesting so you're like
i'm going to
reject you before you have a chance to
read no i mean all my bad experiences
had to do with guys so just the same
with you and women like i'm
like there's nothing there for me we're
not going to have anything in common
you're not going to like me
yeah let's just get this over let's not
let's not
do this charade yeah which turns out is
not true i have lots of guy friends
i've been working on that for about
three years so i love you yeah which is
weird right
my boyfriend loves you they know they
don't
they have to compete for the women's
yeah because i've already won on that
they've already lost um so that was
really interesting like but do you find
though that
with your trajectory of success which i
want to talk about in a second that that
you have encountered competitive shit
with women yeah
but like i don't i don't like just keep
it with me
you know like you experience moments of
like cattiness or attitude or not
feeling welcoming it's like minimal it's
not like
crazy and it was usually like with older
women too like
especially when i was younger i would
feel so like oh
okay like they don't like me but
you know it's just it's i think it's
just like a guard up that
and i don't think anybody's like really
means to do it they just do it as like
their own like
defense they're insecure yeah yeah and i
just remember like seeing you
and going i know what
girls used to do to me yeah and
i don't want to be that like i want to
break the cycle and i remember like
going up to you and being like welcome
yeah you did i'm so glad you're here
so badly i'm trying so hard to undo
the conditioning and the social
construction that there can only be one
woman
and you know because i used to do like
all those shows where there'd be a bunch
of comedians and you'd be like okay
there's another girl on i gotta fucking
beat her yeah why not try to beat the
guys too why not try to beat everyone
the first time you her and i hung out we
hung out for like four hours straight
and i was like this bitch
releases resentments like you were
talking about like
some things that had happened to you in
the past where i was like i would still
be seething over that i would still be
like coming up with counter arguments in
the mirror like there's still things
that i hang on to
like fights with you know exes or or
women or in work situations where i'm
like
i'll just wake up in the middle of the
night and i'll be like yeah and i'll
like come up
with the retort and want to get them i
know i want to restart the fight just so
i can throw in the banger like i
remember like
like i had an ex call me a lot once in a
fight
and you just retain that he goes you
know whitney
you're a lot and i was like what like
not a cunt
not a bitch not a whore like a lot like
you it was just like so weird because i
was like wha
like it's such a vague insult you know
what i mean i don't know how to get hurt
by it it was just like so confusing yeah
it's one of those rorschach tests where
then you end up just having like now i
have to come up with the insult for you
like i have to fill in the blanks
and um you have that written on a
necklace now
a lot because it was such a big deal for
me
and it was very because i spent my whole
life trying to be a lot i was like
that's what i want to be
like you and then i remember i woke up
in the middle of night uh
and i went do you know you're just a
little
that's what i should have said and i
came up with it two years later
and then i wrote a tv show about that
moment and then they gave me a necklace
i love that
if you ever see me in the car on the
interstate i'm having a full-on fight
with someone in my head
if someone calls me drunk that is a
compliment as far as i'm concerned it is
yeah but
like you did that in a positive way like
you know it's not like you
went out and tried to like plan an
attack on somebody it's like you use
that moment and that story to
make it like carry on and
you have to sublimate it into something
and
you know it's just interesting because i
was just thinking about you
and you know and i maybe i was
projecting i think about you a lot
um because we're always texting um it's
this is an intervention frankly it's
enough i need to set a boundary with you
um but uh i was thinking about you
because i was like
you did actually last night by the way i
think you told me okay well i gotta go
now
i'm like okay yes do your thing bye i
think i said like i'm not texting
anymore
yeah yeah sometimes i do that cut me off
yeah she will text that yeah she's like
we're done now and then send your text
after it and go i'm not responding
anymore because we're not texting
anymore today
that was me yesterday i was like i'm
asleep but i like it though because
you know i want to get better i'm cut
you off in the middle of your story but
i want to get back no interruptions on
this show yeah sorry i'm so sorry no how
dare you interrupt me yeah
i get beaten later um i think
you said you want to get better at it oh
yeah your dog in a chokehold
you want to get a thing you want to get
better well i think for me
the texting it's more that my in my
friendships now because i'm working so
hard for my friendships to be
resentment-free
and to not allow my friends um
to not be codependent with them so that
it doesn't breed resentment later you
know like when i'm texting somebody
i don't want you to respond if you can't
because then you're gonna i'm exhausting
you by accident
right right you know what i mean yeah
it's like esther called me today at one
o'clock and she's like hey and i'm like
i'm working she's like sorry it was just
sort of like if i take this call right
now for 30 minutes
i'm then gonna be mad at you later so
but you don't want me to be mad at you
so it's
my job that's the best point in
relationships and i don't know why it
takes so long to get to that point for a
lot of them of being able just to be
blunt
and like just you know honest like i'm
doing this for us
yeah i'm doing it so we can stay friends
yeah no it's true though because
even with me like i'll not talk to
my friend batch for like a month and
i'll we'll just be so busy doing stuff
and then all of a sudden we'll get
together and just be like oh like
go over and we're not mad at each other
for not calling we're not like if you
want to talk to somebody call them if
you want to you know
and it's also in a bigger way now i
always know where i stand with you
so if you say you know whitney i can't
text you for the rest of day or like i'm
going in to record i'm going to shoot
like i'm not i like to do it because i
like to know if someone's on their phone
or not yeah so it's like
i just like to say hey i'm going to be
offline until 8 pm just to manage other
people's expectations so they don't
think i'm rejecting them or whatever
but i also like it because when you say
like i can't talk right now then when i
come ask you for boy advice
i know i can trust you when i say to
these jeans look cute and you say
yes i can trust you you know what i mean
like i just i feel like i was in so many
relationships with people for so long
that we're just so full of shit
just so like kissy assy unctuous like
yeah i love that on you you're so cute i
love that guy yeah no date him and it
was all like everyone was going through
puberty yeah we're like
running a presidential campaign with
each other
guys to each other why are we
bullshitting each other so much like
what is this
yeah you know honesty is like yeah and
it felt like
work and it just felt like like and i
think it took me so long to realize that
friendship should be
energizing not depleting i think that's
probably why i trusted you right away
too
because like you were like that right
away you know you kind of told me how
you
what you thought like when you could do
something when you couldn't do it oh
yeah then i didn't text you for eight
months she cancelled like 20 times
it's fine because she was like hey like
i got this and i'm like okay i get it
but obviously i'm gonna teach you about
it but i love that because i
i i really wanted to start a
relationship on an honest because i was
like i could absolutely
see her for an hour out of obligations
so that i
cause okay so she we text to make a plan
which i don't do with everybody you
don't have to make plans with fucking
everyone
no one has time for that okay like if
you know when you meet somebody like we
should hang out it's like don't say that
if you don't actually want to hang out
with them
because then you just made a new friend
by accident i do that all the time
i'm like we should hang out and i'm like
fuck it's like the how are you yeah and
then they're like okay
and they don't really want to either and
then you're both sort of doing this
thing you don't want to do and you're
just like oh god
okay here's my number uh we want to go
on a hike and it's just like well it's
just like
both hate fucking each other and uh just
check it off i love making you friends
with someone by accident we're like we
should hang out which just means buy
it means buy yeah but i feel like you'll
say that
but you not many people actually go
through with the hangout
if they didn't mean the hangout
interesting right because i
don't say it yeah you would just say it
and just kind of did you go through with
things
i think the ultimate intimacy is being
able to be silent with someone it is
yeah oh yeah
and i used to look at couples when they
were out eating
dinner yeah you know other couples
purples but i used to look at them and
be like
oh how are they just not talking they're
just sitting there eating that's so sad
but
no it's so we ran out of things to talk
about how depressing and now i'm like
that is the
fucking hottest relationship yeah yeah
cause i i remember thinking that
i'm just staring at them like oh like
like i felt conversation
it was just interesting because i think
making new old friends is very hard
you know as you get older and you have
to you have to be able to just like i
mean we talk about red flags so much on
this podcast but you have to be able to
like bob and weave people
you know and like your energy right away
but i just i don't know you just
represent so much progress for me
because also
i'm gonna say something crazy like i
know i'm not supposed to say this i'm
gonna get canceled i don't know but i
remember like
when i first i met you and then you were
funny and i was like oh my god she's so
funny i'm sexist what is that
and i'm i'm like oh thank you why am i
surprised she has fucking a billion
followers on instagram like the the the
jury
has spoken well half for and then half
for the funny
is that why yeah i mean why am i jealous
of
you a little bit that's okay
it's okay it's a condom this is what
every strong friendship is built on
right yeah
jealousy it's weird and i i don't think
i could have been friends with you
ten years ago not even five years ago i
don't think i would have been insecure i
caught you at a good time
you really did because i thought
in my mind i'm like oh like this is how
you've always
been no you are no no no no comes across
that way oh yes
yeah george sorry um george is here with
us and is obsessed with amanda obviously
um
but yeah no i don't think i would have
been secure enough and so
thank you for showing me that i'm the
best no you're and i'm not jealous of
you at all because it's
awesome it's taken 10 years i mean
you've you got it all
you're the full package anybody that
gets whitney is very lucky
well so i want to ask you something
sorry yeah anyways
yeah agree anyway obvious that we know
everyone knows that that's enough about
i
know that we're on camera they know but
here's the other thing i want to say is
i think we need to talk about this as as
a society which is like
comedians look we criticize everything
we're glib about everything
so but what is this thing you've really
taught me
and i think it's because i'm jealous and
i think it's because i'm insecure and i
think it's because i'm
older that being famous on social media
to me was a little bit like oh i did it
the hard way
yeah there's a little bit of that but no
no no but now i see it's way harder to
do what you did
than what i did and it really fucking
annoys me because
and i think it's really i remember the
first time i saw you coming with a group
of comedians i was like oh i need to go
and be nicer because i don't want them
to throw any attitude because they like
to think like well we did the road and
we did it before the internet and we
sent out
mailers like there's some sort of glory
and
in how um uh sort of masochistic
comedy is and oh god there's nothing
easy about what you do and i think it's
i just want to talk about that because
the word influencer i feel like has even
become
you know weird word but you guys are
taking over the world and i want to sort
of debunk these weird ookie
yeah i mean perceptions it's not
something i
ever was like i want to be an influencer
like i'm never
i didn't that wasn't even like a thing
when i first started was
2013 and i wanted to do acting
yeah and i was like all right i can't
get these auditions without a reel so i
need to create a reel
and then i started doing so you were not
getting auditions no
i wasn't i couldn't get a manager or an
agent because i didn't have a reel so
it's like what comes
first you know like i can't and so i'm
like all right you know what screw it if
i want
people to be able to see the variety of
stuff that i can do
like i'm gonna do my own content and
show them okay here's my reel
and then some of my friends did youtube
at the time and they were always looking
for different actors and stuff in their
youtube videos and i was like hey
like anytime you need somebody i'm
available so you're proactively reaching
out to people
oh yeah like i'll work for free i'll
work for free yeah just to build a reel
and then at the same time this app vine
came out and
then it was like these six second uh
videos that were comedic
and i was like this is perfect not every
video is
comedy but i saw the ones that were
performing really well were
comedy videos and i had fun watching
them i'm like oh i can create stuff like
this and this is great because it's like
you know a complete opposite of sexy you
could just be self-deprecating
silly or um like just having jokes it's
like comedy is just like the complete
opposite of like what how i wanted to
rebrand myself
and then in doing that i was like okay
you know i'll put these videos out just
so i can learn how to edit and learn how
to do storytelling nothing's really
going to happen with it
i didn't think it was going to be a
thing for me but i was
main focus was just to be in youtube
content
and then in posting my own short six
seconds you're not getting paid for any
of this
no like yeah you're not gonna be at all
like i
i had like three different jobs when i
was in college i did like bartending
waitressing and even like when i was
like 14 i had like i had like three jobs
my whole life
but then um throughout my whole life
constantly having
jobs but i then i started doing the
divine videos and people started
watching them and i'm like okay this is
something like i'm getting a thousand
views that's a lot
and then i started posting more and
posting every day and i started to get
like a million views and i'm like okay
well this is
i don't know what this is but like this
is great like this
has to be like you know building
something
and giving me some sort of platform and
then
i just started doing longer form
learning how to edit more learning how
to produce
more and how did you learn how to do
this stuff do you just taught yourself i
just watched
different youtube videos i watched a lot
of different like other
comedians and stuff i watched like i did
classes at ucb for instance inspired
but that's that's what helped teach me
like even when i was
watching different sitcoms and watching
different shows i would look at
like okay this is the angles like i
never went to film school and i didn't
know like
the 180 rule or anything like that so it
just made my i still don't know the 180
rule
so it just like made my content better
and watching all this stuff that
i was like okay i can make it more
cinematic and then once i started making
money i started reinvesting in my
content so i can bring up the production
value and
still grow my audience so then i started
doing on youtube facebook
snapchat was like the top 10 most viewed
on there from the improv stories that i
was learning like when i was doing
improv classes so i was able to do it
every day and it was like a full
it still is like a full-time job which
sounds like
crazy to people but like you wake up
right away you
grab your phone which is probably not
healthy text me yeah
yeah text whitney and then um
by the way it's not not healthy do your
thing
yeah get the bags of money the reason
i'm so fascinated by
you and what you've done is like
you know you didn't wait to get
permission
you didn't wait around for a bunch of
guys
in their 50s to decide you could have a
oh i had those meetings out here too i
like i would and i'm like okay that's
not you know this isn't being productive
because i would meet different
producers and me being young and i was
like well how old was i like 20
21 like when i first came out to la and
now
oh okay this is a producer this is great
like oh he has a project that he's
working on show up
and like nothing it's just
weird and i'm like yeah you're always a
weirdo
the number of weird days i went on that
i thought i was just like oh yeah
when you have meetings with agents it's
at nine o'clock in a hotel
yeah i was just like well this is a
crazy business yeah just eyes wise they
must be so busy
yeah like i just was like i had no i the
amount of awkward weird dates that i
went
on and i i do actually i don't i you
know i've publicly talked about you know
the crazy shit that's happening in this
business but i actually just kind of
like have sympathy for the men that
tried to lure me in at that time because
i was so ambitious
yeah and i was like all about fucking
making it like
showing up and they thought they were
gonna like seduce me and i was like
anyway so how much money do you take i
know and then i think and i'm like
pitching them ideas
and they're just like there's no way i'm
gonna fucking get
he's it ambitious like i mean i wasted
so much of their time actually
i feel like i owe a lot of them
apologies like sorry about that
i wish wait is this another break we're
taking this the second break you just
say it again
is that yet you know there's two breaks
are you saying we're taking another
break because the first one you said
we're taking a break
we're taking a little break just that
you're just gonna leave that in there
when we sing that
yeah that's a good idea sure okay great
i have some questions then
um i noticed you haven't paid off my
school loans yet so i had to go to
earnest
how does that make you feel do you still
have school loans
[Laughter]
um interest rates
loboville loboville uh university no i
went to
i went to a real university
um interest rates have hit record
lows i don't know what that means and i
went to college but i know
i know that it's good news yeah when you
borrow money they want you to pay more
money back because i don't know
good deeds don't go unpunished am i
allowed to say this college is such a
racket would return my diploma for cash
right now like
in never used never even opened it so in
the it's still in the package
i feel like you really when it comes to
the merch when it comes to marketing
stuff
your degree shows up every now and then
i've used it now but have you ever asked
to see it
no yeah no i don't you see it no i don't
need the little piece i mean to frame
it's like 148
but i just i i i'm glad i went to
college
if you went to college great i think we
can all agree
that when these like envelopes come in
that all of a sudden have like a red
stripe on them because they went to
collections
uh these how was the last time you got a
bill
dude dude i know that when my college
loan bills they'd come in they'd come in
and i'd ignore them and put them in the
trash and then all of a sudden they'd be
in like red
print and then they have to text me they
it's they they know where to find you
that's for sure yeah um
they i said new phone call earnest
um if you're still paying the same rate
that you paid when you graduated
odds are you can reduce your monthly
payment save big
even if you have refinance before
today's low rate
um makes it possible so that people can
save by refinancing
now i'm reading this off a piece of
paper i don't fully understand it
but i know it makes your life better in
this nightmare of like having the grim
reaper nipping at your heels for your
college loan payments
this is your chance to be relatable
hollywood earnest i'm just saying
earnest is the easiest way to refinance
your student loans
saving you time and money i just
remember like i blacked all this out
because it was so traumatic every time i
get a college
loan bill you're like how could books
have been that expensive
and when you're going to college you're
like oh someone else will handle that
you just assume
that when you go to college that yeah
because you're 18 years old and they're
like you want to take out 200 thousand
dollars
you're like yeah isn't that what i make
per month when i graduate yeah you're
like definitely you'll be an interior
designer you'll definitely get it back
yeah i'm like what do you mean i'm gonna
work in a magazine
and i'm gonna make a million dollars a
year like kate hudson
i watch sexy the city i know how this
turns out that's what i'm saying like
i had no idea how money worked when i
agreed
to have these freaking loans i'm gonna
write one column and pay all my bills
ernest is helping us clean up the mess
which was that decision at 18.
uh earnest offers customizable loan
terms
no fees uh you can even combine private
and federal loans
that's cool having one single payment
with one low rate they do all of it for
you
if you've already refinanced a loan no
problem
you will still be eligible to lower your
interest rate again
plus the internet loves earnest customer
service they're rated 9.4 out of 10 on
trustpilot
so you'll always get the support you
need and you know the internet doesn't
want to
give that kind of rating and if you've
ever been to the financial aid office at
a campus
it is not a 9.4 it's not
start saving today our listeners are
going to get a hundred dollars cash
bonus when you refinance a student loan
at earnest.com
whitney that's a 100 cash bonus when you
refinance a student loan at earnest.com
whitney go to earth.com whitney ta-da
terms and conditions apply today's
podcast is brought to you by
whoop whoop it's a fitness
wearable that provides you with 24 7
personalized insights to help you make
smarter
lifestyle choices that was me reading
the copy but i'm going to go off for a
minute here
it is a big deal that we get to work
with whoop
is whoop is like we're considered
athletes
that's what it said in our thing i was
like excuse me
this swimmer's body honestly i was
really
you could be an athlete but i was like
wait a minute i was psyched when they
were like whoop wants to sponsor i was
like what like joe rogan uses whoop all
the athletes that i follow use whoop
like us like scientists use well like
i'll watch podcasts with like hardcore
scientists they're like and then i
checked my whoop
band for my rem sleep and i was like
damn we're
serious we made it i am a sumo wrestler
these stuff okay so this is a whoop band
you guys have been seeing me wearing it
on the podcast for the past month i'm so
obsessed with it because it tells you
i should read off the copy but i'm just
gonna i'm gonna wing it because
as we know i'm authentic authentic
so it tells you how you know when you
like wake up and you like don't know if
you slept well or not
and then you're kind of just like like
before you've had your coffee you're
like i had a shitty
uh i didn't sleep last night i wake up
and i know if you haven't slept well
that's true based on the number of text
messages i sent you
that's your whoop band yeah i'm like why
i don't even need this who knew
but like and then you wake up and you're
like i didn't sleep last night and then
you're like
in this narrative that you didn't sleep
or you're like
i slept 10 hours last night but you
probably didn't get
real rem sleep and you actually aren't
as rested as you think like
i i just feel like we shouldn't be left
to our own devices
in terms of like guessing how hard we
worked out
how much we slept because i can't trust
myself
to make those calculations you need a
real device what ban
i thought i was working out really hard
the last couple years turns out
ha wasn't so and i thought that i wasn't
sleeping a lot and it turns out i sleep
a lot
but do you sleep good i sleep very well
i'm a great sleeper the whoop band does
not correct vocabulary but here's what
it does do
the way it works is you wear the whoop
band i'm wearing one
this is the color that i requested right
benton well they the
professional athletes we got some extra
colored bands so we have pink ones green
ones black one you can change the bands
that's pretty cool
so cute i really wanted this olive green
one because that's my color
every day when you get up whoop gives
you a recovery score
based on your sleep your resting heart
rate and your heart rate variability and
then it lets you know how to approach
your day
whether it's time for a big workout or
if you should take it easy because
sometimes
you know if i work out really hard and
then i don't get enough sleep it's like
i shouldn't work out the next day it's
going to be a useless workout i'm going
to freaking injure myself my muscles
haven't healed
like there's no point so i basically my
whoop makes my decisions for me because
i'm not capable of making a dollar yeah
the activity
i mean it tells you how many calories
you burn your average heart rate your
max heart rate the duration
and it also like challenges you it tells
you your day strain your recovery your
sleep performance i got a hundred
percent on my sleep performance
almost three days in a row and i've
never been prouder of anything i've ever
wanted
i got a hundred you're me huh
that's me you were i'm a great sleeper
yeah you are good i get like awards on
here but there are times that i
thought i got really good sleep because
i slept long but i actually had just
like taken like
nyquil or something weird and they were
like you got like a 89. yeah it's
because it wasn't
my heart rate wasn't what it needed it
tells you the time you spend in bed
the disturbances you that affected you
the efficiency of your sleep your
respiratory rate
and four stages of sleep lying in bed
and being knocked out
drunk does not count as sleep it's
there's awake sleep there's light sleep
there's
rem sleep and then there's slow wave
sleep so the certain sleeps
that help you actually restore um your
neural pathways when you learn something
new
your quality of sleep is more important
than your quantity of sleep it also
tells you your
latency which i've never heard of before
but that is the duration that's the
amount of time it takes you to fall
asleep
yes i fall asleep in three seconds on
this one
that's probably a record for whoop and
then there's an
app where you can basically just check
it constantly so it's like it's actually
it's replaced instagram for me instead
of like just scrolling through x's
photos i now just go on to see what my
muscle recovery was my sleep quality
it's like
it's like the only news i look at at
this point it's fascinating whoop has
also introduced
respiratory rate into the app an
increase in respiratory rate could be an
indication of illness before you start
to feel any other symptoms
so whoop can actually let you know if
you
are sick before you even know you're
sick and
in this climate what's more
important than that whoop is here to
help you know yourself
better than before actually when i want
to start sharing
whoop stats with the guys i date before
i date them i don't need to see your
credit score i want to see your whoop
scores
i want to know what i'm signing up for
it's the future really
truly if you want to be a professional
athlete like us
um whoop is offering 15 off right now
with the code whitney at checkout
go to whoop that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com and enter whitney at check out
to save 15
sleep better recover faster and train
smarter optimize your performance with
whoop today
for me it was almost like comedic
because
you would hear those things about
hollywood and then you would come out
here and then you would see it you'd be
like oh huh
that's it that's it that's that thing
yeah you're a actual cartoon
yeah like this is but what i love is
like you just like took matters into
your own hands you know
and i you really made me realize a lot
about
you know the work that i do which was
all
you know in this the business of
hollywood the byzantine sort of
kind of um very dysfunctional
unnecessarily complicated an unnecessary
number of velvet ropes
um yeah you made me realize
how fucked up it is in a lot of ways
because you know i've spent all this
time on these boards and having these
talks about how there should be more
women behind the camera and there should
be more female producers and there
should be more female editors and like
how do we get how do we recruit more
women and people of color
and then this bitch shows up at my house
with her camera she comes in she directs
the whole thing she edits the whole
thing and i'm like wait a second
this is this is like not this is a
hollywood part this isn't a problem in
you know youtube and in social mm-hmm
you know what i'm saying like it's just
like
it it like blew my mind that like
actresses are going to the oscars being
like wearing sweaters that say like more
female directors only six percent of
women are
over here just like you guys are just
like uh really there's no female
directors because i just made
30 youtube videos this week they got a
hundred million views like what the fuck
are y'all talking about
it made me realize how ridiculous
hollywood is yeah but it's
you know same same but different yeah
yeah yeah
it's a different thing but it's like
there's so many do you feel like that
there's
this weird dissonance between social and
hollywood because hollywood has an ego
they like to think they discovered
people yeah they don't like america
deciding who they like and it being
forced on them
they want to decide who they like and
force it on america i feel like it's
changed
a lot though since when vine first
started
it was like nobody cared like oh you're
getting
hundreds of millions of views and what
does that mean it's like well those are
like people that care about
yeah what the person that they're
watching on a consistent basis so it
must mean something right
and then it's just like nobody really i
didn't give
unnecessary notes yeah like they just
there's so many fake jobs in hollywood
like there's people whose job at
every tv show that you see that has that
sucks by the way just
it's because there was like five lawyers
and like
guys that went to college for marketing
or advertising who are just like need to
justify their existence so they're
giving the writers notes they're just
being like
and they're only just regurgitating
things that they heard their boss say
when they were interns they're just like
we're not rooting for this character
like
can we make this character more likable
and you're like what and then you just
start servicing these dumb notes from
these people that aren't even writers or
artists
and then you're trying to please
everybody and then you plea and then the
show sucks yeah and everyone's mad at
you yeah
it's like what are we doing too many
cooks too many cooks in the kitchen yeah
and they
and because now it's becoming clear that
they're dead weight they have to justify
their existence even more and more and
more like i just had to call the
notes call the other day on a tv show
and it was just like guys
just go to do it just go to get a phd go
back to school it's over like it's
everyone's like trying to
be the person that gives the most notes
so that they seem vital
because content creators have completely
disrupted i mean you've really
ruined my career yeah i'm sorry but like
i
i feel like but you're a content creator
too like
you're a creator period you know you put
so
you put shows together you put content
online together like you
you help your friends put their own
content together so it's like you're
always
producing and packaging and doing all
that yourself too which is like
essentially it's kind of like a skill
that
a lot of youtubers especially the ones
and the new
the new influencers or whatever you want
to call them starting out
the qualities that they need to have or
to be able to
be resourceful um be willing to wear
many different hats and you know it kind
of takes away from the quality of the
content
if you're doing every single job oh
interesting
but it it does make it so it can be
consistent and you can grow
i just love that you were like i can't
get these fucking auditions i'm just
gonna do this myself
yeah i mean and and it worked like it
was
i was very happy at worst because i was
you get so many no's and it's so funny
like
the most successful people i'm sure you
got a million billion no's in your life
wow trillions of no's
wow
no yeah no i mean it's it's really
to me i feels you i had a i love that
this is why we're
we get along like i have a very sadistic
relationship with the word no because to
me it's just like
every no is like oh i'm closer to the
yes yeah it's just like a little
breadcrumb it's like oh i'm closer i'm
closer like i
i never saw and it's delusional in a way
and i think it's partly because
i had such a hard time getting attention
from the adults as a kid like to me no
just meant try a different tactic
yeah which is why stalkers go to jail
which is why
which leads to lots of crimes oh yeah
but no is always just like a
try something else yeah every time
yeah yeah before i met you huh you know
before i met you i asked if i could host
your show you were going to do in
nashville they told me no
five times that i couldn't host it and
then i was like well
i just showed up and then yeah and then
i said well can i go watch a show and
they're like we don't have any tickets
so i bought one and that's
and then they were like another can i
just meet her i asked the manager and
they were like well no she doesn't want
to meet anybody so i just waited that
line
i love that yeah and here you are
fighting with stalker
yeah no fighting with like the best kind
like it's it's so good
the difference between stalking and
being persistent
yeah i now sound like the vowel cult
later that you never treat pain and
suffering um
but yeah you know i think that for me
it's like there's a certain and i when
people ask me about stand up and i and i
i'm so curious if you guys if this is
the new
similar in terms of the trajectory and
the skill set that you need like
whenever someone asks me if they should
do comedy or how do i know if i can do
it and it's it's
so painful and hard the only thing i
know to say is
you have to love failing at it yeah if
you don't love failing at it you'll
never succeed at it because most of it
is just failing
which a lot of people see the success of
it and they don't see the fails
that part so i mean it's interesting
watching like all
even with like the private shows and
stuff yeah all coveted everything's good
oh yeah yeah my yard yeah but even
watching people
go up and try jokes fail at it and
switch to jokes a little bit and then
all of a sudden it's hilarious
yeah like it's like okay like fail and
then
do better it's but yeah everybody
congratulates you when you're pregnant
but nobody knows how many times you got
fucked
yeah exactly this is the perfect way to
put it
that's true because comedy is is
failing is what it is you know that's
that's every night you go up until you
get it right you know what i mean like
failure is part of how you succeed at it
so it's like
you know but yeah i mean it's like i
think about benching all the fucked up
jobs you had and all the fucked up shit
you went through and it's just like
i still work five jobs
for what for one person think about if
you hadn't had all those shitty jobs
like you a lot of your best jokes are
about them
and then a lot of the funniest shit you
say is about them like it's all
gold i mean think what you're saying is
very similar and correct me if i'm wrong
to what you
do because i mean anyone that's on the
internet that started their career that
way like that's
all trial and error correct it's all
like what works until it until i figure
it out
and you read the comments you read like
because there's constructive criticism
yeah
exactly how do you know the difference
between because i'm a big fan of
criticism
yeah like there's this like no comments
it's like yeah but also
they're your boss they're the audience
they're the one that we're trying to get
to buy what we're
selling what you're creating for yeah
yeah and there are a lot of people
obviously who are just going to try to
hurt you and troll and that are just
going to project and be insecure and
just throw grenades at you or whatever
um i love what bill burr says about mean
comments to celebrities he's like if i
was a kid i knew that i could like say
something mean to a celebrity i totally
fucking done it it's hilarious yeah you
know what i mean like but um
how do you know when to internalize
something
and when not to or um i think it's
like pretty to me it's pretty clear
maybe it's because i've been doing it
for like a decade
but like you know when somebody's just
bluntly saying go
kill yourself or like you know don't do
that
yeah you don't do that and that's like
not very concerning it's not flirting
but if it's like oh you should have done
this or this wasn't that funny
like i enjoyed the other video it's like
oh okay like
because that's also someone that's super
invested that's someone that watched the
other video it's like
i always get torn about that because
when someone's like oh i don't like this
joke as much as this other one i'm like
fuck you and i'm like wait
you know all my jokes like you're you're
rating them you're getting them in an
order like you must love me yeah you
know like
rate it's like movies like this movie
was good the second movie you didn't was
okay
yeah like not up there so keep up with
that and you took the time to comment
you love me do you think the difference
is the fact that you're used to getting
critiqued like in a room from writers
and people that are giving notes
and you're used to all your critique
being from comments yeah so you have to
look at it a different way
yeah i like i still read them all
it's a lot but i'm like a speed reader
now too i can't
like just eggplant eggplant eggplant
eggplant yeah squirt squirt
squirt squirt delete yes is is engaging
because i think a lot of people listen
to this podcast and i think everyone
um the future of everyone's business is
going to be
this is it yeah you know what i mean
everybody should have a presence on
social at least for their business i
think and like what in especially
these youngins uh what is your
relationship
in terms of the fans like how much
engagement is
the most you can possibly really do i
think
like because you want to show i mean
obviously
you care about your audience right or i
hope you do
so if you're going to post a video sorry
i'm gonna get really granular if you're
gonna post a video
and you you do a lot time to go like i'm
gonna have to respond to like comments
for 20 minutes like i'm not just going
to post it and walk away yeah
no that's what i do i just post it and
walk away no wonder i have no followers
but that's healthy too
i mean because i'm like oh i don't wanna
yeah and you post it and you move on to
the next thing and that's doing well
it's like i don't wanna get attached to
the validation and what if the guy like
doesn't like i just i
you treat it like a fucking business and
i treat it like a personal
hang or something but sometimes like if
i'm not like
i don't know like i do pay attention to
comments every time i post i post and
then
i'll read through like the the first
ones and i'll reply and
like i'll engage for like probably like
10 minutes and then
i'll just be like all right like that's
good um
and now i'm gonna work on this other
thing because if i stay here i'm not
being productive anymore
like and but then i also have different
ways and forms of communicating like you
do it too you have your
text that you're able to text all your
your fans two through nine seven five
two seven
yeah three oh five six seven seven one
four four seven um
but that's like such a great way because
i i mean i use my tech scene as just
you know obviously you give updates like
if you're touring you're gonna have
different people in different cities
that where you're going and without
blowing up your feed
and knowing like like i'm going to
orlando i don't need everyone in the
world to know i'm going to orlando
orlando needs to know that exactly which
is the best like you can you can do it
that way yeah
and even just doing like inspiring
messages or like something that i
learned from that day
that i think could be helpful to people
i'd share it like on the text too
really like not to get you know i don't
overdo it to where it's like all right
like
gandhi thank you yeah yeah yeah we got
it yeah but it's like things that really
like help me then i'm like oh you know
this could be good for people and then
seeing the feedback from that it's just
like it builds like a closer
relationship between
because then i'll go and like look at
people's texts reply to some
and yeah but i can't i really enjoy
doing it
yeah i really like i love the texting i
love people
i i love like it's taken me so long to
fucking have good ideas that i'm so
excited to share like i'll never get to
be a psychiatrist or a therapist i don't
think i'll ever have time
but like people will ask me the
relationship stuff and i'm just like i'm
so excited to solve problems don't okay
don't send me too many yeah
um but like i like the texting like it
doesn't feel like an obligation to me i
think
the texting i really like doing because
it's one-on-one with your fans whereas
like
instagram everyone can see your
responses and i'm so
i need to really get out of my head
about this because i'm like i'm like
love you thank you thank you and i'm
like everyone thinks i'm phony and
everyone thinks someone
i always think everyone else thinks
someone else is doing it like i i don't
want it to
and that's the thing like i assume
everyone thinks that you're doing it
yeah well honestly i am maybe you are
like i used to think that about
celebrities and stuff too
like when i first started like growing
online and i would get a message from a
celebrity i'd be like
that's not them like that can't be that
it was from jeremy pittman it was
definitely him
yeah you know and that you know it's
them and then like you figure it out
but it's really he i'm sorry this dog
is i thought he was just gonna go to bed
you love amanda so much i love him
it's like that's i feel like it's just
not an entertainment though that's in
every type of business that you ever
want to do if you want to be an
entrepreneur
you have to do it yourself like there's
really not
any handouts and then even if like okay
people will probably be like
all right well what about the random
people that just go viral out of nowhere
and then all of a sudden they have a
career
it's like well then they got to stay
there well you got to eat yeah and you
got to start eating tide pods and shit
yeah it's like you got to sacrifice a
lot yeah
it's just that's probably sometimes
like even more pressure mentally and
even more work for people too
like i haven't exp like my
i guess me going viral was like building
blocks but now you see people that just
go viral out of nowhere and then i see a
lot of the comments being like oh
like they're famous for doing nothing
it's like okay maybe the
video you don't know what went behind
all the other videos and if there was
nothing
now they have to work so hard to stay
relevant there because the faster you
climb the faster
like you can lose your relevancy to so i
i think sometimes it's even more work
okay we need to slow down our climb
benton
yeah our climb well like
think about it because like your the
relationship with your audience is so
short like you don't have like uh
in-depth years years years building your
relationship
and then all of a sudden you just grow
and people support you they can easily
not support you anymore because they
don't have a strong connection
besides oh yeah they have to grow with
you yeah reinvent yourself as they
reinvent themselves
well that's interesting because i did
feel like for the longest time
um that the audience that i
sort of had at the beginning like that i
wasn't allowed to change
you know what i mean you've changed as
someone who's followed your career i
know
you are a different person really do you
feel abandoned by that
no i like it better um yeah i mean you
are
completely different from it's like the
girl
like dane really like he sort of got so
famous
doing a certain thing and then he went
through a lot of fucked up shit in his
life and changed and they were like well
where's the fun guy
yeah well i you know so it's like i've
always sort of like watched comedians
and been like i hope i don't stay stuck
i hope i don't stay the same
you know i hope my audience like allows
me to grow and change and not be
you know that's what keeps it
interesting though like i feel like if
you're always just the same it's like
okay well i i know what to expect i'm
don't really need to tune in today yeah
exactly that's like
yeah they can predict everything so what
is do hashtags
matter uh yeah i use them like
not i'm not talking about mine i think
there are a lot of people i use them to
search i'm gonna speak
for myself i think a lot of people are
like embarrassed to try
too hard because all the instagram like
their stats are all
public now sort of like it used to be in
our business
you could kind of pretend you were more
successful than you were nobody really
knew the ratings nobody really knew how
much money you were making nobody really
knew
yeah you know it was sort of this vague
thing where it's like if someone was on
tv you're like they made it but you have
no idea what the actual metrics are
um and now it's like i think i think
i definitely think we're all you know or
i'll speak for myself and maybe my
um uh the people my age were a little
embarrassed to try and fail
so we're like i'm just not gonna try at
all i'm not gonna do hashtags well you
just said you don't do hashtags on your
post
right i do like on hashtag
coolpic hashtag cerningcalendar2021 yeah
or like
you know like four things that are
important but not every post no
okay just be you know and if i can
search it
yeah but i should because probably i
would be discovered by like
different people like because i i
think of yourself as a consumer and then
how you consume things the tools that
you use and that's what people are using
that could find you too this is my
problem i
don't make stuff i worry about what
comedians think of me
yeah i worry about what my friends think
they're not my audience
yeah they're not my concern they get
free tickets
that's like the the fear of what other
people think yeah
so it holds you back so i'm like i don't
want to put a hashtag they're going to
think i'm trying too hard
but i am trying yeah no that's not a
secret yeah i'm trying
very hard yeah i like this everybody is
yeah that's the thing
why am i pretending i'm not trying hard
i just spent 45 minutes taking a picture
it's not cool to not try i don't know
where we all get that that's not cool
yeah yeah you're so you're just a loser
that has nothing yeah no but i mean i
think it goes back to like high school
when it's like the straight a student is
the dork and then the guy that gets the
f is like the cool guy everyone wants to
be friends with it's like now they're
your boss so like yeah yeah
it's so true you know how that story
ends yeah but like tagging like i had so
much shame in the beginning i didn't
want to tag brands i didn't want to look
like i was trying i don't want to look
like i
wanted anything and i want to you know
like i just had so much weird shit with
social media yeah
i don't yeah i mean i do my best
when i just don't try to think about
who's your friends that are following
you yeah or if like celebrities are
following me or if like
producers are following me or like
directors are going to see it like i'm
just like
fuck that you haven't hired me yet bitch
these these people hired me yeah
followers these are the ones that are
like hair those should be the people
that you
care the you care about what their
comments are you care about what they
think a little bit and
but not to the point that goes back on
it too i don't know because you also
create for yourself a little bit too
yeah because you want to be happy in
what you're creating you want to be
satisfied and passionate about it and if
you try to create things
just to satisfy other people that may
not be the audience for you but are
still there
like then you're just not going to excel
so it goes back to our favorite
millennial saying of being authentic
oh yeah that's what we really like if
that's the clothes you wear post it if
that's the if this is an ad post it's an
ad just be
honest is people really want that's all
i want it's it's weird how
um being like a normal human is like
you get points oh yeah in l.a people are
shocked you don't get no
i we did this charity in my backyard the
other day um
uh this show for the um hydrocephalus
foundation it's for babies that have
fluid on their brains and they have to
have surgery and it's terrifying and
whatever
and they're like thank you so much and
they're giving me candles i'm like you
don't get points for helping
babies this is like everyone's like
how can we thank you i'm like thank you
for letting me
do something for someone else like what
a joy and they're like but here's the
gift card i'm like i don't want it like
i you d when do since when do we get
points for not being a sociopath this is
crazy
yeah yeah every time i hold a dorm for
somebody in l.a they're like
shocked look thank you they're like what
are you the only thing that's like
like what are you doing and i was like
i'm holding the doorbell for you for you
to leave and she was like oh like so
confused i was like
okay yeah okay what's the first game
we're playing benton because i have this
theory that you and i are really really
close but we don't really know each
other that not
does available most and then the
absolutely that's already white besides
what more can i do
like grab that okay have you ever played
the newlywed game i don't know
because i've never been newlywed and
nearly engaged well this is the newlywed
game for millennial friends
whitney what in the event of a tragedy
who would you ask in your will to wipe
your internet history
great question they get to see all my
cookies
literally it's their job to get rid of
it before anybody else sees that
okay got it that's easy i wrote down
what i think
okay whitney show us your answer oh it's
me
show us your answer yeah wow
amanda knows you're so much better
already okay okay
see now we got that i got the hang of
this the coffee one that was a shitty
question fun we should have done this
the whole podcast
amanda yeah describing inspire people
describe in three words what whitney
does for a living
okay do i have to write that down you
have to i don't know you have to match
words
three words what does she do for a
living
then they can be descriptive or they can
be like the actual this is too vague
i didn't make the question wait we'll
pick better i like that question
really because newlyweds have to guess
each other's jobs
what she makes people do oh you know i'm
right
what you know i'm right there's no way
newlyweds have
describing what you do so like it would
be like if i said like i would say
whitney makes people
laugh cry the hardest dave's ever
laughed at this podcast
and the least i've ever tried to be
funny what this is insanity
are you ready what you do
no way wrong with the cult stop oh
she looked oh you guys while we were
fighting
she was she's like uno i said run your
cards
i run a call now i saw the
fully running a cult now i see i i can
do it i think i have what it takes
uh and i think it's a good business
model
okay so many miss comedic opportunities
okay i want this to be a good one for
amanda i'm gonna start
um vetoing these questions if i don't
like what a surprise
um okay let me look you're trying to
veto them now just don't know
is there a prize um what else can i take
from whitney
i was gonna say you can have literally
whatever you want what do you think
amanda wanted to be when she grew up
okay
hold on you're writing a lot i know i
read that much
like this is a weird the way that i'm
writing it you're gonna don't deduct
points because i'm too specific
wait i show mine then you show oh that
was
what you want to be a vet yeah i love
dogs
that's mostly kill dogs but i didn't
know i thought they saved them
yeah they do that a little bit are you
judging her childhood dreams yeah
very aggressive i thought movie star i
thought she wanted to be like julia
roberts
no i didn't figure that out until later
oh yeah
damn it and that i wanted to be a vet
what did i want to be when i grew up
shouldn't we do a reverse
no okay i would okay that's not how the
game
works so based on pinterest or wherever
the fuck she got this weird quiz off of
reddit
poker game they really does run a cult
by the way i do look at that google it
a camp what is um whitney's most
hated emoji
oh do you know the answer
do you hate them hold on i hate a lot of
emojis
whitney's most hated emoji
i think it's a trick question it is a
trick question
hold on i can't draw i'm not great at
driving people can see your board hide
your board
hide your anger magicky attach your wife
how'd you get your wife okay that came
from
all right i got mine all right i'm ready
ready what okay go ahead
that i didn't cheat i didn't cheat on
that one to be fair the answer was all
of them
that is you just have to draw yeah that
is
so she gets me squirt
i hate the squirt emoji yeah it's funny
like are you coming
like what is this it's like isn't it i
mean
it's like come like you're lit did you
just send me a cum yeah
you're gonna come i'm going to send that
one you're going to knock it off
like i never had somebody sitting in a
little trolling mouth beside it we're
coming
oh gross okay that is that was really
i'm really
proud of us we can stay friends we can't
say friends i think
we're in we're back i feel better now
okay
go whitney what would be amanda's idea
date idea date ideal date
i know ben 10 will just like skip words
and then you're the idiot for not
understanding it
uh did you know what i meant and then
you're a bully for asking him to
clarify true drawing what would amanda's
ideal
my ideal date amanda's no questions will
never be about you unless i'm asking
amanda
okay okay so what is amanda's ideal date
mine yeah so whitney writes your answer
and then you write your answer after one
well you can remember everything at the
same time yeah uh ideal date
ideal date what oh you just thought of
it
okay she just draws the squirt emoji
again
[Laughter]
okay got it ready
fucking kind of
i kind of got it yeah it's like
progressive
massage if you're in a poor now it's
poor not a poor name i said that because
you hate the word
hate it she hates it one time somebody
said porn in front of us it was like a
30 minute conversation she's like why
would you say that
just stay porn i was like let this
person leave who was that
old like scuzzy friends i don't know i
love
massages really favorite thing you don't
like no
i've had two massages in my life and i
really i stopped them
i crave them i just want like elbow and
my shoulder blades just like
oh yeah i i don't like people touching
me i i
i'm too codependent for massages because
i get all wrapped up
in trying to prove to them how good it
feels and then i'd saw them and then it
stresses me out because i don't know how
it's awful yeah i know i want us on the
video version of this podcast to have a
little meter down here that just ticks
all the time to say codependency
addict codependent that's really funny
that could be a drinking
i know someone's drinking oh people make
drinking this all the time on the show
they're like every time whitney touches
her hair every time she
cleans her glasses every time i
interrupt somebody
that's so funny fuck that's amanda you
get a pretty easy one what's whitney's
favorite
food is that easy
is that easy i don't even know the
answer that yes you do
okay got it okay
i show mine first yeah you're not gonna
get it i didn't even know that
[Laughter]
is that
that is my favorite food to put on my
face no fried pickles is my favorite
food you didn't know that i always said
baked potatoes
huh when i'm on the road i eat i
wouldn't say potatoes or
dips just dips in general tips are good
yeah
no bless you thank you oh god bless you
sorry i'm allergic to being
misunderstood pickles
fried pickles are my favorite food on
the planet with some blue cheese
dressing
fuck out of here blue cheese blue cheese
or ranch dressing
fried pickles nothing better i was gonna
say buffalo cauliflower all right one
more um
one more or just like as many more as
you think are good whitney
sir what irritates amanda the most
she doesn't get she's everyone gets mad
i know but she's very
this dog is like pawing at you we need
to work on boundaries
can we work on your boundaries please
sir um i hate it when people do that
with their dogs when they just ask them
rhetorical questions instead of training
them you know when you're like at a dog
park you cannot do that
and someone's dog is like attacking your
dog and like hey what are you what are
you oh
can we stop that please sir you could
have my kids when i went to the mall
people used to ruin everything and mom's
like you're hurting my feelings
oh when you messed that up you hurt mom
i'm gonna do this are you sure i'm like
push that kid down
yeah okay what makes her the angriest
what's her we'll i'll change it for you
what's your biggest pet peeve biggest
pet peeve
this is hard pet peeve we'll just put
anything and we'll move on okay i know
but i'm stumped
i'm stumped i'm stumped wow um
because i'm pet peeve oh i know
oh i know you so well okay what's your
answer amanda
don't tell us that long again the
context is closed she only wrote one
word but
okay really what is it no i mean you oh
smoking oh uh i thought it said stalking
he's like that is really annoying he's
saying that
your house with guns what did you write
whitney i wrote this
is just because we're so close when your
makeup melts off
oh that's a good one that's a great
answer do i know you better than you
know yourself
not melt pressed off we've talked about
that three times now yes because we
initially helped she came in and i was
like what do you do to your face
right now no it's not at all but didn't
i gave you that lotion to use
yeah but i put it on i think i need to
exfoliate yeah before
at the charity show we talked about it
too yeah yes it's the thing yeah
it's a problem i have my makeup crusts
off because you have dry skin no she's
used to doing makeup in florida where
it's humid and you're here there's no
humidity i love humidity
and here i feel like i'm just shriveled
hmm
well i know you better than you know
yourself next time okay we're playing a
new game
okay that was that game i don't know the
last time we went over good somebody
that was smoking
oh i think smoking is so hot really i
hate it
i love a guy that smells like smoke and
that's smoking
i hate that i love it it's just sexy to
me like it's
not a healthy it's like tattoos and
motorcycles it's like i
might like the bad it's just like you
don't give a shit and you don't care
about life you're gonna die
soon all the listeners tattoos are
healthy i just mean like it's like uh
i mean it depends on the tattoo yeah but
i think for me it's just like that bad
boy thing that i just like the guy i
also
love smoking like you like a guy who
smokes you like he won't live long
that's yes get him and get perfect for
my commitment issues
no but i and i love smoking like i'll
smoke i don't smoke
i never got hooked on smoking more
because i was just like
broke at the time when i would have it's
just the dry cleaning bill like i just
didn't have enough
clothes the dry cleaning but you're such
a virgo i'm just saying like the dry
cleaning bill like
you like i couldn't afford it and
cigarettes are like eight dollars now
like
i'm glad there were a lot of financial
obstacles like i think taxing cigarettes
i think it works because i literally was
like
it's just too expensive to be addicted
to this but if i if someone has a pack
of cigarettes i'll like have a couple
and i and rogan talks about this on a
show a lot it does if you don't smoke
and have like a cigarette it gives you
like a buzz like a pretty good buzz
i'll have a couple like their grapes
have a couple of them yeah i will i'll
just
chain smoke and it makes me feel like
i'm in paris or something i don't know
it's just so in the movies
i know movies got you actually a lot of
people in europe i think still smoking
yeah
yes for sure i'm so unaware look at me
smoking i feel so sexy even though i
look disgusting
it's just like but it's interesting how
people like
are like fully aware of like the side
effects
that could happen with smoking but like
they still do it because i guess every
once in a while to have a vice
yeah okay this next game you're gonna
need your phones for okay
i'm gonna ask you a question raise your
phone if you choose to do it great
if you're not me and the other person
who questioned it wasn't was
have to pick something for you to put in
your instagram stories
okay i don't like the second part i just
wanted to show them control freak
let's just do the first one okay there's
no consequences then it's a fun game
there's no rules
um you have to take tests and you can
both just
in that case you can both answer the
same question so okay the first question
is what's the eighth most recent photo
in your phone
oh god
i took a screenshot of my phone so that
counts
three four five six
seven oh no oh no this is so
weird this is embarrassing
mine's very sad and boring what's yours
it's a photo of me it's a throw
like uh oh you scream pinterest you
screen grabbed a blanket you're gonna
buy
no it was like i already bought it but
it was i couldn't find it on the website
and then are you doing an ad right now
what is that always hustling she's like
anyway so brooklyn
brooklyn and promo code cerny damn she's
always hustling
mine is just me and a camel that's your
eighth photo
all the other photos are showing too i'm
sorry
[Applause]
so the second question is what was the
last text message you sent say
what does excuse me the one i sent back
to them
or that they uh the last no the last
text message in your if you look at your
phone right now what's the selection
not what's up text yeah text wait you
know what it was
guess guess what the last word i sent to
someone was word you only said one word
it's one word is it k
that is probably a very popular text of
mine
what do i always say
it's three words wild i wrote wild in
all caps
to sarah from the val because today
the uh verdict came out that claire the
secretary
from you found the woman and became
friends with yes we spoke last night for
two hours
yes oh and you couldn't text anybody
back
last night i told ben we're starting her
own chat
wow so i wrote wild because the um
uh what's her name heiress who
bankrolled the sex cult leaders uh
claire bronfman
was sentenced to seven years in prison
and she sent me the article and i wrote
wild always on brand you're not the only
one hucking around
yeah that's really good i like how
quickly she found them
from after watching the vows yeah like
it was the same thing with monica from
cheer she was like tomorrow we're
friends like what are you
yeah and then she's like it's really
hard for me to find female friends
yeah yeah yeah i see
yeah unless they're in culture cheer
coaches all right what was your last one
uh she just showed us oh no you there's
your picture i showed you it
so boring thank you i like that you're
boring
it says thank you yeah it's first two
how much does
uh falco way 8.6 pounds
thank you that was your new puppy very
nice yeah thank you yes about the puppy
god
all right who's the most famous person
in your contact list
i mean oh whitney
um no i'm probably the least famous in
yours i mean
sandra bullock probably no it's always
standard good one
i mean is he i mean i it's so winter
bullock is probably fucking you
frankly i mean there's different kinds
of fame now there's there's
the days of like like universally not
famous or oh like i went to she loves
the speech everyone's famous to someone
that's what she's gonna say say it i'm
just
saying are you pulling the tactic of
what that girl did to you about hyping
them up and said they have to talk
themselves down
because you just compared me to sandra
bullock here's what i'm saying i know
you so well remember when we went to
remember when we went to the rupaul's
drag race celebrity edition and there
was a
celebrity there named madison beer that
i was like i don't know who this person
is
and you're like she's got 40 million and
i was like oh she's famous and you were
like
me too no no and then on
celebrity drag race with phoebe robinson
when i did the interview
for my celebrity friend i was billed as
phoebe's friend yeah
that was so funny it's because nobody
else invited like
a famous person to come be their friend
it was like my mom my soccer coach then
it's like whitney and
full glam yeah and she's like anyways
phoebe's been my friend for years and
they're like
phoebe's friend dude they didn't even
put my name on the
lower
okay so madison beer is the most famous
person on the planet and i'm
phoebe's friend like that's how the
place to be though
phoebe's cool i just think no i mean i
just feel like
fame has changed the days of a michael
jackson of madonna where
everybody knows the same person as i
feel like are kind of open and you can
thank amanda for that she's helped
change yes thank you
she broke fame what is your daily
average screen time no for the week nope
no yeah i will show you my tits before i
show you that you've already seen it
what's your screen time
no i said no i'm not showing you it's
going to be too embarrassing
here's the hold on i'm just glad she
didn't want any of the rules okay here's
the thing
i feel like screen time is not accurate
i think that if you don't
log out of the app it keeps clocking you
as on the app i love conspiracy theories
i'm telling you i think it works like
that because like
okay if you embarrass me in front of my
family
yes yes so because there are times that
my screen time is like
seven hours that seems low
do you wanna know my daily yeah that's
the question my daily average
daily oh god yeah this is i don't i'm
too embarrassed i don't want to say it
give it to me i'll tell you
no it's too embarrassing all right i'm
just going to tell you
i work really hard and i've really been
trying to step up my game with stories
it's your phone you can be on it as much
as you eight hours 28 minutes
that's your weekly average daily that's
not right give me your phone
why there's no way you're on your phone
that little amount of time
i'm not on my phone that much that's not
a lot that's
all day what's the total at the bottom
right here where is the total
total screen time 33 hours and 53
minutes for the week
yeah okay yeah day nope day is six hours
one minute
what's the last photo you sent to the
person that you're dating
oh uh oh well i'm not really dating
anybody
well on the last four podcasts that you
were so that's good
we've been through four podcasts where
she's like i was on a date
and where people were listening like
what girl but if i show you you'll know
who it is or no you want
i might lie you have to show us the
photo you don't have to show us anything
else show the photo
yeah oh it's a photo okay you go first
where okay fine it's me in a uh
this is shit we it's my most recent
yeah i don't know if is it you and a bra
from our last open
no it's me in a black flag shirt
that's way more embarrassing than the
brawl
because we don't understand why what did
he respond
wow uh did you mean to send this to me
he said red flags no black flags yes
this is um
this is mine if it's just your pussy
and i just turn it whoa oh is that
your calendar yeah give me that wait you
know what's amazing about this
is she's she's there's like suds and i
was like wait did we get
i just do it for fun i love this photo
but it does have little white sparkles
on it i was like no it's very
maybe i don't it could be misleading i
get it i love
this bath photo where's that bra from
uh i don't know they sent it to me
influencers man they don't shop anywhere
so where do you buy that they're like we
don't know they just send stuff for us
for free we've never been in a store we
don't have to
shop online no i think this is i think
um it's cute it's hard to find good sexy
bras
yeah but this is like an a lot of my
bras are like old
like i have like a lot of older bras i
don't really wear bras
that often yeah that makes sense
what is that what why because you're
still wearing the maiden form across
your hearts
no i just don't wear that oh like that
won't no okay so the bras are cute that
i have and just like you don't wear bras
like every
day yeah i don't really like buy new
bras like the most bras i wear sports
bras but
it doesn't occur to me to buy new bras
it's so true you know what else i didn't
know you had to wash bras until like a
year ago like i'll wear bra
oh like people were like i went to a
friend of mine's house and her bras were
hanging i was like why are your bras in
here and she's like well i washed them
and i was like
are we supposed to wash our bras yeah i
was like whitney's like i wipe
back to front i do like back to red
no yes i do no no you don't right back
in the front
no you won't right front to back wait
wait
[Laughter]
i don't know how i do it i don't want to
do it down here it's from
i'll text you what i do i don't really
send you a
yeah i didn't know you were supposed to
wash your bras until very i'll also
ride my bras till the bitter out yeah oh
that shit
underwater there's a wire stabbing you
you're
failing yeah like that's how steve irwin
died literally
it was just like a giant it's a metal
going into your heart
from his bra like yeah uh look he had a
secret life what's the la who's the last
person you called
um whitney miranda cosgrove
okay you have to pick someone else
because the next question leads into it
well it was also esther my accountant
okay you have to call that last person
now and let them know that you're really
disappointed they don't care more about
your hobbies
content all right on speakerphone please
don't laugh me please don't answer
oh i have no service no i will get you
on the line no
i'm on the wi-fi all right wait are you
calling esther to do this so it's gonna
be hilarious oh fuck
can it be a facetime or does it have to
be a call just do a call we can if
denied she denied me i'm so happy though
like i don't know how she would take
that she quits
i have no idea anymore wait so i have to
call
my next one sure you can find another
person if you want to
whitney yeah i mean feel free hold on
esther
but i do it has to be a call not a
facetime you can do whatever you want
but i call it to see it's easier
my dad
she might be on the plane no she's there
in her room she can't leave for two
weeks yeah she has nothing to definitely
answer
yeah i don't think my you have to do
facetime audio
we get it internet nerd you know how to
use
technology
is this an accident no i'm just calling
you
wow what are you doing
um i am laying on my couch
um i'm just calling because i just want
to say
something real quick okay it's kind of
just like
as we become better friends like just uh
like i just sometimes feel like you
don't
care about my hobbies what is going on
[Laughter]
is this a prank am i on a podcast right
now
did you ruin that quick didn't you
we're playing me and amanda and benden
are playing a game called yes sir
hi esther called show me where you have
to call the last person in your phone
and tell them you're disappointed that
they don't care about your hobbies
oh my god i knew you didn't call me for
real
this is a horrible place i knew esther
would react terrible to that
this is a sick game
cut to whitney being like i can't talk
anymore today
yeah i did for any second you you knew
right away because i called you not
facetime that something was fishy
well i just yeah it was a little too
soon for you to call
after our last call
[Music]
all right well we tried have fun i miss
you guys i am disappointed in your
thoughts
about other things
[Laughter]
i'm really disappointed you don't care
more about my hobbies
[Music]
disappointed is a word i feel like we
don't use all the time though
mm-hmm that's why i turned it into rough
yeah it's questionable you can say like
bummed out it feels scripted
when you say something you're
disappointed it gets serious you're like
what
but it's weird to jump from hey what's
up to disappoint it feels like a prank
it's really sad when everybody just
denies your call i know
i'm actually truly disappointed none of
these people care about your hobbies
because you should just call esther too
and tell her the same thing i'm gonna
try one more person none of them answer
your calls
i'm gonna try one more really sad i'm
gonna call my mom is this why you guys
like hey
insta fam because it's truly yeah the
only people that will write
family real family the life of an
influencer is really sad
mom you have 30 million friends yet none
yeah my mom
come on mom
hey hey mom hey
what's up um i just kind of wanted to
talk to you about something
okay
i am i just
really i don't know how to say this
i just really wish that you would
care more about my hobbies
what do you mean
um i like to go on hikes i
like to i don't travel
and you haven't asked me once what i'm
doing
like for fun
what do you mean
what do you mom yeah my friend's mom
asks asks her all the time
what she's doing like are you having fun
and you didn't even ask i went for a
hike and i had all my stories and you
didn't even ask me if i
enjoyed it
okay all right i love you
yeah i'm so sorry miss ernie
miss reed miss reed sorry she has a
different lesson oh
my god sorry oh my god that was
so funny and so like heartbreaking that
was so hard to listen to
i'm surprised you you didn't you you
were like that
like those bomb mothers like i was like
she was like this bitch is gonna call me
and say what yeah
i'm gonna freaking kill you now you're
on the
if i knew you would podcast that nice i
never would have let that happen
i didn't like usually she wouldn't be
so this is really good thanks mom josh i
love you
i love you yeah
did you have a good hike yes
yes it was with whitney i'm so glad
oh you look so great right now on camera
so
like now you're like the best mom in the
world well you are
i love you i love you come on i thought
all successful people had bad childhoods
this is fucking up my whole theory you
have to let that go
yeah all right mom love you love you
mom hello well that was fun
i mean i wasn't like usually she's like
she likes to tease me
but like i think she really thought that
i thought she didn't
love me that was also really good acting
that was really you're like i don't know
how to say this
i jumped right to it mine i didn't sell
mine at all yeah you were just like
esther i'm mad at you
okay and what's new it's not out of
character for me at all
so the next one okay last one because
i'm sweating and i'm in a swampy
i mean there's only four more and
they're pretty good okay let's go then
who's the last person you searched on
instagram
oh god this is gonna be fucking
embarrassing
is it gonna come up if i just go
i don't how do you see that if you go to
your search and then it just shows you
pretend
you don't know how to use instagram it
shows you in a list like a list
underneath the search bar do you see it
there'll be little x's okay the real one
okay can i let me walk you through a
couple
because two of them i searched because
you know when you go on instagram and
like
a photo will come up but then it'll like
if you haven't been on in a while and
it'll go down
and i'm like i didn't see what that was
yeah so
this dog so beth stelling comedian who's
been on this podcast i saw a photo
and i didn't get to like fully see it it
was like her and
um somebody and i was like oh uh will
forte and i was like wait a second are
they dating like i didn't know what's
going on so i went to her page but
that's not
that wasn't like a full search
and then kaylee coco her sister has like
an exercise line and they're like oh
just go to her instagram so i searched
that but that wasn't like the last
creepy one i did
the last creepy one i did was kate
beckinsdale
glamour straight up that's the good one
kate beckinsdale i would just wanted to
look at her body and face
yeah amanda you kind of like kate
beckinsale she does i agree
thank you i agree look at her just
receiving the compliment
not something i could do i would fight
with you that would be a tooth and nail
but that's because it's fun all right
what's yours that was my if i'm going to
be honest that was my last creepy one
but i don't i don't think mine
are doing it right seth rogen also i i
think i dm'd him about being on the
podcast yeah mine was
my friend inanna and but it's i don't
know why i did it
yeah uh lauren bates hair that my hair
girl
you're just enjoying instagram i'm
looking at my friends i'm looking at my
hairdresser well you like
use it as a business i use it as a
gossip
i use it to hurt myself i i use
instagram to hurt myself you use it to
be like how's this hair person yeah i
mean
your relationship i know that's your
name that's your real intention who's my
ex dating yeah like
i hurt myself with instagram i'm
learning a lot yeah
i feel like i i look up people sometimes
and i just don't
i don't know why it's not showing me who
hmm like i feel like you can clear them
yeah but you're just not ookie you're
not ookie about it okay
i appreciate like you're not ookie about
it like you're not using instagram to
like be shady and like
like stalk people you just use it for
business i need to learn from you
i need to do that but maybe i'm stuck in
my bubble and i'm just doing it in like
my bubble of people and i'll go through
everybody's stories
and then i'll be like right that's how i
stalk people i
follow them and they say ah okay see i
don't watch people's stories as much
because then it makes me anxious yeah
because i think i need to be doing more
or less i'm like oh they
did theirs look so good that's my
favorite is the stories yeah
huh i like it all right um so this is
the last one we're in the positive note
you can pick any random person in your
text messages one through eight
you can't go past eight okay and you
have to send them a positive
encouragement well it's just to give you
it's to give you rules it could have
been me i'm gonna do whatever you want
but you need rules
so one through eight pick one of those
people okay you have to send them a
positive encouraging text message
i like that my mom i'll send it to my
mom
uh which by the way i need to change my
phone number i just got a text just
f straight up from a 786 number
can you look up that area is that floor
786 this is someone not in my phone
that just says this is the yacht we're
gonna rent to celebrate on
when our heat win the nba championship
it sounds like florida
but have to ban group sex on this one
lol
wait that's not florida it's miami yeah
but 786 you said
it's miami do i just say wrong number
why mine saying
don't say anything you don't have to
respond to that wrong number okay one
two three five six seven
uh i think i should do it to
me that is so nice it's i'm going to do
it to sarah from the vowel
sarah from the vowel sarah edmondson
well i guess she deserves it yeah yeah
the silence breaker from the vow who
busted up a sex cult i'm going to write
i am so inspired i'm in all of you
you should be proud i mean because today
the woman went to prison who funded this
call who's the blonde lady on the vow
the very first one to leave
can you just google it instead of asking
me yeah i don't know i thought you would
know
the mistress of the vow i remember her
name what that sound my point was she
didn't get enough attention
benton likes to just like ask me
questions i would never know the answer
to on the podcast like i'm his personal
google
like if you just look it up you could
say oh what about this girl what would
be fun about that no
no one wants to hear a bunch of people
not know the answer to shit that's not a
good one
he does this all the time really then
how is jeopardy a thing and then
who wants to be a millionaire and then
benjamin bunton
and then ben and also one day i'm gonna
know his name
one day i'm gonna learn benton's name
it's gonna be a big deal benjamin also
just throw things out
like yeah i heard that like ring worms
like mostly live in bananas and i'm like
is that true and he's like i'm not sure
and i'm like
okay is that not how you talk to people
if i was having a conversation with you
i
we know what we're saying and then we're
going to pass it on we're not going to
just guess this is an information i
thought it was a lecture
no this isn't like a brainstorming
version of things we might know
no it's like back to like the debate
that just happened they have a fact
checker
yeah you need a fact checker that's true
we need someone sitting here just be
like that's
so then you can speak freely and then
someone would be like nope
that's not it i love that that's gonna
be our entire podcast okay so
what am i gonna write to sarah edmondson
from the vow uh you are brave
uh you you are kind you are smart you
are important
you're going to be a leader of the next
cult yeah yeah i can't wait to
get you into my my cult i can't wait
till you see
instances i can't wait to use silence
break me
you're saying hey sarah big tattoo idea
she might not
show up hey send nudes
but love you have something encouraging
well i already sent her saying today i
hope you're proud and feeling triumphant
today many people are safer because of
you
oh that's good uh okay my neighbor
i'm really grateful for my neighbor
she's really nice i feel like my mom
really deserves
yeah your mom i need to text your mom
too yeah how about taylor tomlinson no
she's good she has she's she we need to
keep her we need to keep her humble just
really
like make esther feel like something's
up again and just
you can't do it she'll never quit
talking about it i'll say
remember the other day when esther was
like hey thank you for making me feel
part of a family and she started crying
yeah we should put her on medication she
was really nice to everyone
you were included in that too uh-huh she
was saying that we had a serious comment
i i'm gonna i'm gonna text esther i love
you and i'm so
glad you're my new sister what about
that
oh she's gonna be like is this real
she's gonna make is this fake again
you're the best i said i love you and
i'm so glad you're my new sister you're
the best
that was a good text yeah she was i do i
do
i do kick her around it's gonna like the
sister word is all you need in that like
she's gonna be like she's gonna send oh
here go and she wrote back
lol
i told you she wouldn't believe you
what did she said out back the squirt
emoji yeah
your least favorite yeah i understand
all right that was good we need to we'll
clean up the messes that we made on this
podcast
um that was not
that was i was not far
i swear we'll clean up the messes we
made on this
i don't i swear i would own up to it if
it was a fart i swear
i will stay if i parked it i would leave
you
i came over there it was funny because
your face when you hear a fart and
you're not sure if you should say
something and you have to like check
it what was that did you fart bent it no
wow i heard it from over there well it
was i thought it was like bathroom
i thought it was the chair i thought i
leaned back and chair farted that's
always oh i thought it was your mic when
you moved your mind oh no
i would say if i farted i'm one of the
i'm one of those people
well there's nobody in your bathroom it
came from over there you said
a lot of celebrities have ghosts in
there or think they have ghosts in their
houses i need to figure that joke out
yeah no no you got it yeah it's closed
it's uh no i
if i fart i'll either just walk away
like if i just walk away in the middle
of a conversation it means i'm farting
oh to do it somewhere else yeah yeah if
i'm just like i have to take i'll take a
fake
like you'll fart there no if you're to
notice
no i all depends on who it is if i want
to get out of the conversation
um uh no although i do know someone
shout out to eden sandler uh i'm just
fucking named checking i don't even care
anymore who's married to catherine han
and he wrote on a show that i did and he
said the best thing when you've been in
relation for a long time if you're
fighting about something stupid
what he'll do is he'll just fart and
she'll start laughing and it's just like
what are we doing like it's such a great
way
to end a stupid fight that's a good
strategy because i'm like
you know like you fart humans fart we
fart but if you just fart during a fight
it's like
fuck i love you yeah like because it
makes it like reality yeah
yeah it just like takes intense like on
that note yes
just end the podcast i always end these
very awkwardly is there anything else we
need to talk about
your juan your we haven't talked about
any of your litany of businesses oh
that's fine
two minutes it makes most of amazing
wine beef oh my wine yes
oh you said it like with the knocks in
another one and she just went that's
fine we don't have i don't whatever
no it's actually really you've tried it
it's fucking i'm
i'm an alcoholic and a wino so i like
lots this was like
even non-white and it did not give me a
headache
here's the thing i can't really drink
white wines and roses because they give
me headaches this one i had no headache
the next day
i had no migraine and it wasn't like all
dehydrated
yeah and it's like it's palatable for
like
everybody that's tried it maybe i hope
they're not just being nice to me but
like
seems like they genuinely love it and it
doesn't leave a film on your teeth it's
weird it's sweet but it's not like
sticky it's not like um
juice does that make sense yeah yeah
yeah how did you how do you make a wine
did you go and like taste a bunch
just tasted it we let the vineyard do
their thing but
the the wine ratings are amazing for all
the wines we chose like they're all
91 plus ratings on the wine which is
like amazing
and then yeah just like i know nothing
about wine and there's times that wines
will be like 200
i'm like i don't get it and i had yours
and i was like okay this is f
like i this is delicious yeah there's
times i'm like talking myself into wine
being good because i'm like i think i'm
supposed to think this is good but it's
like i don't
it was just like perfect thank you crisp
yeah we're i'm i did it with my best
friend batch what are the notes what are
the notes
um the notes of the rose a rising
rising cherry of the roses falling
raspberry well you know when they talk
about wines and then like there's like
nutmeg yeah they'll be like there's an
unbelievable breeze of pines
always the same like poetic language
i feel like for the one but it makes it
like foreign
yeah it's all i mean everything's pretty
light the rose
i don't know how i would describe it
like i guess it's very it's light like
almost like a makes everyone seem more
interesting that's how i describe it
makes everyone just a little less
annoying it's it's like
not too sweet but sweet enough
little strawberry maybe it is a little
strawberry
and then uh refreshing refreshing crisp
crisp it's very crisp crispy it's like a
gala apple
that's my favorite but not appley don't
get no it's not apple juice like benton
yeah it has and it's not too fruity no
you know it's just
it's fucking so good perfectly balanced
yeah 626 wine
go check it out 66wine.com
[Laughter]
always always hugging that's working
with no
shame and she can do it with see for me
i have so much time i'm like yeah you
don't have to buy you know what don't
watch i'm just
like is that the truth i love it but i
love it like i it's
i'm not mad at her it's she's making me
realize like you can
sell the thing you've worked hard to
make and not be ashamed of it and no
one's gonna not like you it's you that
doesn't like you that's what i'm doing
when it comes to the merch when it comes
to the masks and all the stuff that we
sell i'm always like oh i don't want to
seem like i'm selling this like but yeah
i am
i like celebrities who are happy for
what they've achieved
benton always fucking tells me this why
can't
we give more merch away we're like you
all want it well i feel like i'm like
being desperate or murdered great merch
by the way thank you
yeah it's good i'll benton i love it i
wear that hoodie
all the time no i'll give you the
numerous yeah people are obsessed with
that hoodie
um but i'll order the new merch i'll
give it to you i'm like buy the merch
subscribe to the youtube or don't
like why can't i say yeah every time
we're like
guys leave us comments if you feel like
it if you want to no pressure i'll
delete my account i mean it's whatever
you want i will quit
if you want me to but how else i mean
hopefully everybody has products that
they
actually truly believe in you know and
aren't just like
pushing but that goes back to trust yeah
why that's my theory if we make merch
we should be willing to wear it i like
it enough and i'll wear it yeah
i don't want the last thing i wanted for
you to buy something that you're gonna
be like i'm gonna sleep in this but
here's the thing
i grew up having to make myself smaller
for narcissists because i couldn't shine
too bright and i still have a little bit
of that where i'm like oh i don't want
to
look like i'm bragging and i don't want
to show off
that's what comes up yeah you know what
i mean no but no one thinks that
i mean you just did that i didn't think
that i thought that was fucking awesome
you're like buy my wine i'm like cool i
will
because you know she's not doing that
yeah i know you it's my i need to work
on i need to fucking work on that and if
anyone does think that you're bragging
about something that you made and you're
making money off of
good good i am good
yes thank you i needed that pep talk no
i just gave myself
yeah i mean everybody has a little bit
of that like but you're making me
realize there's no shame in being
fucking
super ambitious and wanting all of it
well that's something you're carrying
around because
you're women or if you're anybody that's
not a straight dude you carry that
around that feeling of making
being smaller am i being am i being in
the way too much space
yeah like i don't want too much like who
do you know what it is who do i think i
am
there's that yeah a little bit of like
the like sort of like who do i think i'm
like what am i
trying to say because i think when i
used to be jealous of comics i had a
bunch of merch and had a bunch of things
and sold out shows like i don't even
like to tell people
shows are sold out yeah and then people
like is your show sold out and i'm like
i don't i don't want to be the person
who's like sold out
shoes like why not which is so funny i
worked my
ass off yeah but like you're actually
you feel proud right i do
what you've achieved like you actually
you're like yeah hell yeah
yeah or are you like yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna move on
sometimes i'm a little hit yeah yeah we
had a yeah
hit hey
[Laughter]
i think yeah i think that like we're at
this time where now like this next
generation is going after shit we just
have to be shameless about it
and if someone doesn't like it or thinks
we're bragging or want too much or being
corny like that's their shit fine don't
know if someone's being braggy and gross
you no they are yeah and then you can be
like that person's gross move on uh-huh
yeah
yeah and if they think i'm bragging fine
it's all about
authenticity
and code dependency on that note
unfollow amanda follow me i can say this
without change
very good but don't know
[Laughter]
it's actually really bad she won't even
do it as a joke she's like
okay yes i can't code like that she's
like you can have a couple
i do giveaways we need to do giveaways
this thing where i i take you know my
talents and skills
and i tell her things and like we should
do this and she's like i don't really i
don't really i don't know if i don't
remember the end of that i don't know
what i think and then like a month will
go by and she'll text me like three in
the morning but you know we need to do
it'll be the
word for word the thing i thought that i
said you said yeah well that's good
because
that's you're you're impacting her life
or someone else will say it and like did
you hear this and i'm like
but whitney doesn't and you do giveaways
in real life
i do giveaways in real life yeah every
time i leave whitney's i have a new
prize that i love
oh yeah we were making we were making
fun of her about that yeah
like today i have a penguin i just like
give i like
people like there's things that i feel
like i have that i'm like you need this
but you're not giving away junk you're
like giving away things that like
are really cool i think there's
something more valuable than giving
giving someone a gift that's your that
was yours
is to me a bigger deal like yeah do you
know what i mean because it was mine and
i like it
i now want you to have it it does depend
on what you're doing
i should give you some of my bra if it's
like a book
if it's like a book actually probably
helped me a lot yeah the like books
like figurines boots like i had these
amazing cowboy boots
that like uh there were vintage cowboy
boots and they were like
fucking gorgeous vintage they were like
so expensive
and i never wore them and they weren't
my style and kesha walked in the door
and i was like they're yours
and she was so happy i've had these
boots for seven years
i've never worn that makes perfect sense
that makes sense no they were like belts
around the ankle
i saw them they were like i was like
what size shoes are you doing like ten
and i was like oh i've had these boots
for you for seven years
yeah like i just love that i love buying
things i mean like i don't want this but
i know someone's gonna
finding a home for them yes like the
fostering you do
i'm like i'll figure out whose this is
later yeah but it's not mine because i
wear the same shit every day like i love
it i like it but it belongs to you yeah
i dress like the kid from stranger
things so it's not
form and on that note thank you guys for
watching
and listening and make sure you
subscribe
and we love you give it a five star
[Music]
rating
it's okay stop pushing your brand stop
pushing your brand
give it a five star rating don't ride
elephants guys thank you
[Applause]